ONE TWO THREE HE SENATE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE ON CORRECTIONS
IN THE JUDICIARY.
PUBLIC SAFETY WILL NOW.
BEGIN CAN YOU CALL THE ROLL.
CENTER SKINNER I'M HERE THERMAL
AKA [inaudible]
SIR ABOUT.
ALL RIGHT SO I DON'T THINK I
HAVE ANY --
CHANGES TO ANNOUNCE ON THE
AGENDA --
OUR HEARING TODAY IS PRIMARILY
DISCUSSION ITEMS [inaudible]
THE ONE SECOND.
YOU WILL BE.
HEARING ONE OF THE BUDGET CHANGE.
BCP'S OR SAY BECAUSE I CAN'T
REMEMBER WHAT THAT THING MEANS
BUT WHATEVER --
WE WILL BE HEARING THAT IN ISSUE
ONE BUT WE WON'T BE ACTING ON IT.
I'M AND THEN WE WILL --
HAVE SOME OTHER ITEMS AS
DESCRIBED ON THE AGENDA.
BUT PART OF THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING IS TO GIVE US A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT --
OF SOME OF THE REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS WITHIN OUR CORRECTIONS
DEPARTMENT NOW BEFORE I GO
FURTHER WITH THAT.
WE ARE -- R.
J. LACKEY MEDI THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
DIRECTED THE STATE AUDITOR TO DO
AN AUDIT OF OUR DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS REHAB PROGRAMS AND
THAT AUDIT WAS RELEASED.
JUST A FEW MONTHS AGO.
AND WE WILL HAVE.
THE AUDITOR HERE.
AT FUTURE HEARING TALK ABOUT
THOSE FINDINGS.
I'M BUT WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
WORTHWHILE TO YOUR PERSPECTIVE
SO.
JUST IN THE CONTEXT ON FREE THE
RECESSION.
CALIFORNIA HAD.
SOME VERY MINIMAL REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS IN.
OUR CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT BUT
WE DIDN'T EVEN ADD.
THE WORD WE DIDN'T ADD TO OUR TO
THE CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT TO
WHAT YEAR WAS THAT ADDED SENATOR
BILL DO YOU RECALL.
OKAY BUT IT WAS IT WAS.
BUT IT WAS OWN MORE.
NO NO NO IT WAS MORE IN THE YEAH
I WAS GONNA SAY IT WAS IN THE
EARLY TWO THOUSANDS SO WAS NOT
THAT LONG AGO.
SO WE DID NOT VIEW.
OUR CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENT AS A
AS WE DO NOT VIEW THAT IT HAD A
REHABILITATIVE PURPOSE UNTIL.
AS LATE AS TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND
THEN VERY QUICKLY THERE AFTER WE
HIT THE RECESSION.
AND WE PRETTY MUCH SLASHED THE
FUNDING FOR THOSE PROGRAMS.
SO WE DIDN'T REALLY START.
REINVESTING IN REHABILITATION
WITHIN OUR CORRECTIONS DIVISION
UNTIL ABOUT.
TWENTY THIRTEEN AND IT AND SO
REALLY WE'VE NOT HAD GOOD
INVESTMENT INTO A MUCH MORE
RECENTLY.
ADDITIONALLY.
WHEN WE LOOK AT I MEAN SO WHAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF OUR
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS?
DEPENDING ON ONE'S PERSPECTIVE
BUT BOTTOM LINE IS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE THAT WE HOLD
IN OUR STATE PRISONS GO HOME.
THEY RETURN HOME AT SOME POINT
OR ANOTHER.
AND SO.
THE ONE VERY VALID PERSPECTIVE
IS IF WE ARE.
HOLDING PEOPLE FOR A CERTAIN
PERIOD OF TIME WE KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO RETURN HOME
[inaudible]
INDEPENDENT OF OF TRYING TO KEEP
RECIDIVISM LOW.
WE OBVIOUSLY OUR JOB IS TO IS
PUBLIC SAFETY.
IS TO DO OUR BEST TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES AND SO
WE WANT.
ONCE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN HELD IN
OUR FACILITIES AND THEN RETURNED
HOME.
WE WE WANT TO HAVE DONE THE BEST
JOB POSSIBLE. TO HAVE THEM.
THRIVE AND BE ABLE TO RE ENTER
IN A WAY THAT IS SAFE FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES.
AND SAFE FOR THEIR FAMILIES AND
SO THAT'S ONE OF THE ESSENTIAL
PURPOSES OF OUR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS.
AND BECAUSE WE HAVE HAD THEM
REALLY IN REINVESTED IN THEM IN
REALLY A PRETTY MORE PRETTY
SHORTER RECENT PERIOD OF TIME.
IT'S HARD WHILE THE LA --
NOT ELIO POLICIES.
THE AN AUDITOR.
HAS IDENTIFIED SOME VERY
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT WE'LL HEAR
ABOUT WHEN THEY AUDIT YOUR
PRESENTS.
IT'S HARD TO DO A REALLY GOOD
ANALYSIS OF THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
NUMBER BECAUSE OF THE SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME.
THAT WE HAVE REALLY BEEN
INVESTING IN THEM.
AND SO WHAT WE WANTED TO DO.
PARTIALLY TODAY WAS TO GET SOME
PERSPECTIVE FROM PEOPLE WHO
EITHER DELIVER THOSE PROGRAMS OR
WHO ARE THE RECIPIENTS OF THE
PROGRAMS TO GIVE US A LITTLE
CONTEXT SO THAT THEN WHEN WE
HEAR FROM THE AUDITOR IT'LL HELP
US [inaudible]
ON ASK HER QUESTIONS AND
UNDERSTAND THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS
BETTER AND THAT SORT OF THING
OKAY.
SO LET US BEGIN WITH ISSUE ONE
WHICH IS INCREASING AND MET IN
MAPLE LITERACY B. C. P. SO THIS
IS A CDC ARE WILL BE PRESENTING.
AND WE HAVE.
ERIC SWANSON OR DEPUTY DIRECTOR
AND RYAN SUZETTE WHO IS THE
MISTER SWANSON'S OUR DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES IN FISCAL SERVICES.
BUT MR SERVICES ARE DIRECTOR.
FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMMING.
MISTER SWANSON YOU WANNA START
SURE.
THANKS WATSON DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE OFFICE OF FISCAL SERVICES
GOOD MORNING THE FIRST REQUEST
TODAY IS. FOR FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION GENERAL FUND IN THIRTY
FIVE POSITIONS IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN TWENTY AT
ABOUT THE SAME ON GOING.
INTO EITHER FORT ILLITERACY
MENTOR PROGRAM ACROSS ALL CDC
OUR ADULT INSTITUTIONS.
AS YOU MENTIONED WITH ME TODAY
IS RYAN SOUSA OR DIVISION OF
REBUILDING OF THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATION PROGRAMS TO TALK
ABOUT THE PROPOSAL.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
ONCE AGAIN MY NAME IS RYAN SEES
I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR --
FOR THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AS
MISTER SWANSON DISCUSS THIS
PROPOSAL REQUEST FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION.
I'M IN GENERAL FUND AND THIRTY
FIVE POSITIONS BEGINNING IN
NINETEEN TWENTY TO ESTABLISH A
LITERACY MENTOR PROGRAM ACROSS
ALL CDC ARE DAHLE INSTITUTIONS.
LITERACY CONTINUES TO BE THE
PRIMARY FOCUS OF OUR
CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION --
AND WE DEFINE IN THE DIVISION OF
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THOSE OF
THE LITERACY NEED AS ANYONE THAT
DOES NOT HAVE.
A HIGH SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY OR
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA THAT'S
REALLY THE MEASURE THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO GET --
ALL INMATES TO PRIOR TO RELEASE.
AT THE TIME OF THE PROPOSAL 53%.
53% OF INMATES RIGHT ABOVE THE
NINTH GRADE LEVEL.
AND 62% OF INMATES I'M DID NOT
POSSESS THE DOCUMENT HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR EQUIVALENT SEE WITHIN
OUR DAHLE INSTITUTIONS.
NOT PERCENT WAS 53% OF INMATES
RIGHT ABOVE THE NINTH GRADE
LEVEL BUT 62% DID NOT POSSESS A
DOCUMENT AT HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR EQUIVALENCY.
ESSENTIALLY MEANING THAT WE HAVE
PLENTY OF WORK TO DO AND MAKING
SURE THAT OUR INMATES HAVE THAT
LITERACY NEW NEED MATT BY THE
DIVISION.
THIS PROPOSAL STEMS FROM THOSE
FACTS --
THAT WE HAVE CONTINUED LITERACY
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS AND WE'RE
LOOKING FOR CREATIVE AND COST
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO REACH THE
STUDENT POPULATION IN NEED.
THIS PROPOSAL ESTABLISHES THE
MENTOR PROGRAM WHICH IS LED BY
AN ACADEMIC ACCREDITED TEACHER
MENTORS WILL GO THROUGH ROBUST
TRAINING INTERCEPT AND MENTORING
PROGRAMS WHERE THEY WERE --
IN MY ALSO COMPLETION CREDITS
AND ULTIMATELY IN GRAHAM.
UPON FINAL COMPLETION DAHLE
MAINTAIN PAID POSITIONS A
COMPATIBLE RATE TO OTHER HIGHLY
REQUESTED WORK ASSIGNMENTS.
WELL THIS PROPOSAL IS NOT
INTENDED TO SUPPLANT ACCREDITED
TEACHERS ARE FACE TO FACE
INSTRUCTION WHICH IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL TO THE OVERALL SUCCESS
OF THE STUDENT POPULATION WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS PROPOSAL DOES
CREATE.
A PEER TO PEER PROGRAM THAT CAN
HELP STUDENTS ACHIEVE THE
LITERACY STABILITY AND
SUCCESSFUL MITIGATING IMPACT
OTHER REHABILITATIVE ARE JOB.
I'M WHO WILL IN TURN HAVE TWENTY
MEN.
THE GROWTH IN THE ABILITY TO
REACH THE STUDENT POPULATION IS
PRETTY SUBSTANTIAL THIS PROPOSAL.
THERE ARE TWO POINTS --
THAT I THINK ARE IMPORTANT TO
BRING UP THAT OFFICE AFTER
REHABILITATION WHICH IS HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO MEASURE SUCCESS.-I'M AND THAT IS GONNA BE DONE
THROUGH OUR TAPING COSTAS --
TESTING WHICH IS BASIC ARM
LITERACY LEVELS THAT ARE TESTED
THROUGHOUT PEOPLE ASSIGNED TO
EDUCATIONAL ASSIGNMENTS.
OTHERS USUALLY YOU'LL HEAR
MASQUERADE LEVELS ONE THROUGH.
NINE AND SO WILL BE MEASURING
THOSE STUDENTS ARE PARTICIPATING
IN THIS MENTOR PROGRAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE GETTING --
EDUCATIONAL LITERACY GAINES AND
IN TERMS OF LEVELS AND
ULTIMATELY WILL BE MEASURING
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS AND
EQUIVALENCIES THAT THEY AREN'T
AS WELL.
SO THOSE ARE MEASURABLE
COMBINATIONS PLUS LOOKING AT
HOURS THAT THEY SPEND IN THE
LITERACY PROGRAM.
HOURS THAT THEY MIGHT HAVE BEEN
AN ACADEMIC MOVING WILL GIVE US
A REALLY ROBUST --
ABILITY TO TO MEASURE SUCCESS IN
THE PROGRAM AND MAKE SURE.
IT WAS ONE FINAL THING THAT I
JUST WANTED TO BRING UP THAT I'M
WAS MENTIONED IN THE PROPOSAL
AND THE LA --
WILL BRING UP PROBABLY AS A
CONCERN IS THE ABILITY --
TO SUPPLANT CBT I IN TERMS OF
CRIMINAL THINKING AS PART OF THE
COMPONENTS FOR THE MODULES.
RELATED TO THIS LITERACY MENTOR
PROGRAM THERE IS SOME CRIMINAL
THINKING ON THIS GOING TO BE S.
THAT WE WERE NOT PLANNING TO
HAVE.
THOSE CRIMINAL THINKING SLOTS
THAT ARE DONE WITH OUR C. B. T.
FACILITATORS.
USED BY OUR IN MAY MENTORS THIS
IS ESSENTIAL IDEA HERE IS THAT
THEY G THROUGH SOME LEVEL OF
CRIMINAL THINKING APPROXIMATELY
40% OF OUR POPULATION ALREADY IS
ASSESSED FOR CRIMINAL THINKING.
SO IF THEY TAKE IT WOULD NOT
REQUIRE THEM TO TAKE IT AGAIN.
THE OTHER PEOPLE THAT ARE NOT
ASSESSED FOR CRIMINAL THINKING
PART OF THE CURRICULUM IS BEING
DEVELOPED AND LED BY THE
ACADEMIC INSTRUCTORS WILL HAVE
CRIMINAL THINKING COMPONENTS IN
ONE OF THE MODULES FOR THE
TRAINING.
AND THEY WILL TAKE IT THERE SO
THAT THEY'RE NOT --
IMPACTING OUR CPT.
LOTS I'M I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS RELATED TO THIS
PROPOSAL.
I KNOW THAT THE LA --
HAD.
SOME CONCERNS THAT ARE IN OUR
MATERIALS YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO PROVIDE ANY THAT WOULD BE.
THE CHRIS MORROW THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE --
AS IS MENTIONED WE DID RAISE A
FEW CONCERNS WITH THIS PROPOSAL --
AT IS THAT WAS MENTIONED BY CDC
ALL ONE THE CONCERNED HAD BEEN
THE C. B. T. --
COMPONENT IN ADDITION TO THAT DO
THE UNTESTED NATURE OF THE
PROGRAM WE ARE NOT ENTIRELY SURE
THIS WOULD BE A COST EFFECTIVE
PROGRAM --
NOTABLY INMATE MENTORSHIP I
HAVEN'T BEEN EVALUATED TO BE
EFFECTIVE IN THIS CONTEXT
PREVIOUSLY.
THAT WE RECOMMEND PURSUING THIS
AS A PILOT PROGRAM.
THE CIVIC I WOULD RECOMMEND
DOING SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN. TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY POINT ONE AND THE
FOLLOWING YOUR WITH FIVE IN MAY.
I AM INSTRUCTORS.
THIS WOULD SUPPORT.
A PILOT PROGRAM AT FIVE
INSTITUTIONS WITH FIVE
INSTRUCTORS ON A LIMB TERM BASIS
FOR THREE HOURS.
WE THINK THIS WOULD BE OF ENOUGH
TIME TO EVALUATE WHETHER THE
PROGRAM HAS.
IMPACTED LITERACY GAINES.
IN ADDITION WE PUT OUT THAT THE
REASON IT'S DIFFERENT IN FUNDING
LEVELS FOR TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THE FOLLOWING YOURS
IS TO ACCOUNT FOR THE TIME IT
TAKES FOR THE IN IT MENTORS TO
GET TRAINED.
I'M GOING THAT THEY WOULD NOT BE
PAID THE CURRENT PROPOSAL DOES
NOT ACCOUNT FOR THAT TIME PERIOD
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HAVE A QUESTION --
WHEN YOU INDICATE THAT?
THERE'S NOT BEEN EVALUATION OF
THE EFFECTIVENESS DID THE LA --
LOOK AT WHETHER ANY OTHER STATES.
I USE AN INMATE MENTOR PROGRAM.
WE ARE NOT AWARE OF ANY IN A
MENTAL PROGRAMS FOR IN THE
GENERAL ACTUALLY RESEARCH IT WE
LOOKED INTO IT WE DO NOT
IDENTIFY ANY.
OF COURSE M..
IT.
A SUCH A PROGRAM COULD BE
RELEVANT NOT ONLY IN THE STATE
IT'S BILL ANYBODY IN COUNTY
FACILITIES ALSO.
I'M JUST CURIOUS AS TO HOW
EXHAUSTIVE [inaudible]
THE AT SEARCH WAS.
WHEN LOOKING TO THE PROGRAMS WE
DO NOT IDENTIFY ANY IN A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY I THOUGHT
THE JAIL LEVEL OR IN THE
PRESENCE [inaudible]
RIGHT.
SENATOR BILL YOUR QUESTION.
CAN YOU DEFINE WHAT YOU MEAN BY
CRIMINAL THINKING.
SO WHERE IS THE DEFINITION OF
HELLO THINKING IS A COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT ON IT.
THAT WE CURRENTLY --
FACILITATE OUR CBT PROGRAMS
ACROSS THE STATE AND SO OF
CRIMINAL THINKING IS --
BASICALLY A TREATMENT PROGRAM --
DESIGNED TO US AT OUR LEVELS OF
CRIMINAL THINKING AND ULTIMATELY
REACT TO THE CRIMINAL THINKING
TO CHANGE THOSE.
DYNAMIC CRIMINAL GENIC NEEDS I
MEAN THAT'S ONE OF THOSE
COMPONENTS IT'S A PEOPLE THAT
HAVE CRIMINAL THINKING.
OR IS -- IS
ACTUALLY A RANGE OF THINKING.
THERE'S A REASON.
YES ESSENTIALLY SO --
WHAT KIND OF --
ACTIONS YOU TAKE.
IN SAY THESE PROGRAMS --
WITH SOMEBODY WITH CRIMINAL
THINKING. TO CHANGE THEIR LEVEL
OF CRIMINAL THINKING.
MUCH OF THE CRIMINAL THINKING
OPPONENTS LIKE EITHER COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL TREATMENT COMPONENTS
ARE REALLY ADDRESSING THAT
DYNAMIC COMMITTED GENIC FACTORS
SO --
ASSESSING BOTH THAT THEY HAVE A
CRIMINAL THINKING NEED GETTING
THEM TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE.
YOU AND THEN MAINTAIN --
BEHAVIORAL CHANGE OR SURROUND US
THE ADDED VALUATIONS --
OF THE CRIMINAL THINKING.
ARE THERE VALUATIONS OF WHO DOES
IT.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
SPECIFIC EVALUATION COMMIT
THINKING BUT THERE'S A LOT OF
CURRICULUM THAT IS EVIDENCE
BASED ON AND I THINK SOME OF IT
ACTUALLY IS IN THE QUEUE RESULTS
FIRST CLEARING HOUSE.
THE NOW YOU OKAY ON REAL TO THE
READING PROGRAM --
THE QUESTION I HAD WHEN I READ
THIS WAS --
A LOT OF PROGRAMS IN OUR
FACILITIES OR ESTABLISHED IN
TERMS OF EDUCATION RELATIONSHIPS
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
OTHER INSTITUTIONS --
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE EXPERTISE.
AND EDUCATING PEOPLE.
ADULTS AND CHILDREN.
THAT -- HAVE --
DEFICIENCIES AND READING.
ERROR SPECIALIST THEIR TRAIN
TEACHERS SPECIALISTS WITH
CREDENTIALS. TO TAKE CARE OF
INDIVIDUALS WITH THOSE KINDS OF
READING PROBLEMS --
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE YOUR MODEL
INVOLVES THAT.
IS THAT TRUE.
OUR CORRECTIONAL EDUCATION
PROGRAM WORKS VERY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ORDER
ABOUT THE READING PROGRAM THAT
YOU'RE PROPOSING THEY ARE
ACCREDITED TEACHERS THAT WILL BE
LEADING THIS AND WE ARE ALSO
WALK ACCREDITED SCHOOLS ACROSS
THE STATE.
SO THEY DO WORK VERY
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THOSE AND
THEIR EVIDENCE BASED PRINCIPLES
THAT THEY'RE AND IMPLEMENTING
WITH THESE PROGRAM MODULES IN
TERMS OF I'M LOOKING AT WHAT
WORKS AN EVIDENCE BASED
PRINCIPLES INCLUDE THINGS LIKE
HAVING A FORMAL STRUCTURE.
MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE DOING
FOLLOW UP THOSE TYPES OF THINGS
THAT ARE BUILT INTO OUR THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE WALK
ACCREDITATION AN ACCREDITED
TEACHER.
TERMS OF HOW THEY ACTUALLY WERE
THEY HAVE SPECIAL CREDENTIALS.
RELATIVE --
TO READING.
OF EDUCATION CREDENTIALS.
I DON'T BELIEVE OUR TEACHERS
WERE ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE
SPECIAL EDUCATION CREDENTIALS
THEY DO HAVE SINGLE AND MULTI
LEVEL SUBJECT CREDENTIALS AND
ARE CREDITED.
INSTRUCTORS DO THEY DO HAVE A
MEDICAL EDUCATIONAL DIAGNOSTIC
EVALUATION OTHER READING ISSUES.
AND WHY THEY HAVE READING ISSUES
[inaudible]
STEPPING DOWN [inaudible]
DURING A DOT A DIAGNOSTIC
EVALUATION.
AS DIFFERENT PEOPLE HAVE
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PROBLEMS FOR
READING METERS.
WIDE RANGE OF REASONS WHY IT.
PEOPLE ARE DEFICIENT IN REASON
AND READING ABILITIES.
ABSOLUTELY I DON'T KNOW ABOUT
THE MEDICAL DIAGNOSTIC COMPONENT
OF IT BUT I DO KNOW THAT WE GIVE
OUT THE TAPE --
WHICH IS THE TEST OF ADULT BASIC
EDUCATION AND THE COST SAYS
WHICH IS FEDERALLY DRIVEN THOSE
ARE TASK THAT.
ARE ABLE TO DIVE VERY DEEP INTO --
THE COMPONENTS OF WHERE PEOPLE
ARE STRUGGLING SO FOR INSTANCE
WE GIVEN ACOSTA SETTLEMENT.
THEY CAN GO DOWN TO THE VERY
LOCAL LEVEL TO THAT OFFENDER AS
OF NEEDS THEY HAVE MIGHT BE
TELLING TIME OR SIMPLE MATH SO
THE CEDIT HE TEACHERS CAN
REALLY FOCUS.
ON THOSE SPECIFIC ISSUES WITH
THAT STUDENTS SO ACROSS THIS TAX
IS A REALLY ROBUST ANALYSIS AND
THE BACK END OF THAT SYSTEM
PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL DATA FOR US
TO BE REALLY FOCUS ON PEOPLE ON
THEIR TARGETED NEEDS.
SO ARE MEDICAL DOCTORS INVOLVED
THESE EVALUATIONS.
NOW NOT SAID NONE OF SOMETIMES
THE REASONING BEHIND YOUR
READING DIFFICULTIES INVOLVES
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PICKED UP BY
A MEDICAL DOCTORS --
AND IT'S QUITE COMMON ACTUALLY
IT'S MORE COMMON ACTUALLY
REALIZE --
WHEN YOU LOOK AT CHILDREN AND
ADULTS THEIR READING PROBLEMS
ARE ACADEMIC TEACHERS AND I'M
SORRY I MIGHT HAVE MISSED THE
QUESTION ACTUALLY OUR ACADEMIC
TEACHERS DO LOOK AT MEDICAL
ASSESSMENTS THAT ARE DONE --
TO DEDICATE STAFFING JUST TO
THOSE WITH ABOVE COGNITIVE AND
PHYSICAL DISABILITIES SO THOSE
ASSESSMENTS DONE BY MEDICAL ARE
INCLUDED IN OUR STRATEGIC
OFFENDER MANAGER THEY LOOK AT
WHEN THEY SEE SOME OF THE
READING PROBLEMS THAT THEY DO A
READING MEDICAL ASSESSMENT TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE.
PROBLEMS WITH HER EYES --
THERE'S ALL KINDS OF REASONS I
MEAN THERE'S A WIDE RANGE OF
REASONS YOU KNOW THAT THE BILL
IN A BILL TO FOCUS.
ON WORDS YOU KNOW THAT'S ANOTHER
REASON --
DYSLEXIA IS --
SPECTRUM.
YEAH THERE'S ALL KINDS OF TYPE
TO THAT --
THE GOVERNOR HAS TALKED ABOUT
THAT HIMSELF HAVING IT HIMSELF
YOU KNOW.
ON IN A VERY HONEST --
VERY PROUD OF OUR GOVERNOR FOR
DOING THAT.
PEOPLE ARE --
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THE KINDS OF
THINGS HE WANTS TO DO WITHOUT.
AND SO I I I THINK THE DEBT.
THE PART THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT
NEEDS TO BE.
EXPLAINED BETTER AND YOUR
PROPOSAL [inaudible]
OKAY -- THEN
ENTERS A MEASURING EFFECTIVENESS.
ARE YOU GOING TO LOOK AT LAKE
BEFORE AND AFTER READING SCORES
PROGRESS [inaudible]
TESTING OF HER EYES TESTING KIND
OF PROCESSES.
YES TO ALL OF THE VERGE OF
READING OKAY --
THERE'S SOME.
IN TERMS OF READING --
THERE'S A LOT OF TECHNOLOGY IS
NOW AVAILABLE.
OF OF PEOPLE --
REHABILITATE THEMSELVES IN TERMS
OF THEIR DISABILITY THAT THEY
MIGHT HAVE --
REGARDING READING SO THERE'S A
LOT OF NEW --
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S BEEN INVENTED --
IN TERMS OF IS IS A MATTER OF
LIKE IN A LOT OF CASES TRAINING
THAT HIGH. TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
READ SOMETHING [inaudible]
AND IS THAT PART OF YOUR
PROPOSAL FOR THE READING
LITERACY.
PART OF WHAT WE'VE ALREADY IS
MACHINES THAT ARE AVAILABLE IS --
WE HAVE A SEPARATE WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF DISABILITY.
REPLACEMENT ITEMS TO HELP PEOPLE
ACHIEVE READING IF THEY'RE
STRUGGLING WITH THEIR VISION ARE
STRUGGLING WITH A TIME BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT WE'VE ALSO
IMPLEMENT IT --
TECHNOLOGY BASED THINGS LIKE
READING HORIZONS OR AZTEC WHICH
ARE PROGRAMS.%
ACTIVELY ACHIEVE LITERACY BY
LEVERAGING COMPUTERS AND GIVING
PEOPLE AN ADDITIONAL STRUCTURED
TIME --
SURROUNDING THOSE ITEMS SO --
THOSE HAVE BEEN IMPLEMENTED AND
THEY ARE --
KIND OF A SUPPLEMENT PLAYING --
YOU'RE GOING TO USE.
THOSE.
TOOLS AND IT WOULD BE NICE TO
KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT.
THAT IN TERMS OF GOALS OF OF OF
AND THEN IN TERMS OF HOW WE
PRIORITIZE.
THE PROGRAM LIKE.
HOW DO YOU ARE YOU ARE YOU
ATTACKING?
SEVERITY --
OF READING PROBLEMS OR YOU JUST
DOING -- IN
A GENERAL WAY.
THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE WORST
PROBLEMS.
OR YOU DON'T IN A GENERAL WAY.
HOW ARE YOU HOW ARE YOU
APPROACHING RIGHT NOW --
OUR MAIN FOCUS IS THOSE THAT
HAVE HIGHER LITERACY LEVELS THAT
ARE KIND OF MEETING THAT I'VE
TARGETED FOCUS THAT THAT CAN BE
ACHIEVED RELATIVELY QUICKLY.
THAT LEAVES MORE TIME FOR OUR
CREDIT ACADEMIC INSTRUCTORS TO
FOCUS ON THOSE WITH LOWER LEVELS
OF LITERACY.
WE'RE NOT XCLUDING THE LOWER
LEVEL LITERACY AS PART OF THE
PROGRAM'S REALLY IS MENTORS ARE
NOT INTENDED TO SUPPLANT.
I'M EDUCATIONAL INSTRUCTORS
WHICH ARE REALLY CRITICAL IN
GETTING PEOPLE'S LOWER LEVEL
LITERACY IS UP TO A HIGHER LEVEL.
AS THE WERE FOCUSED ON THE
HIGHER LEVEL MORE ALSO FOCUSED
ON THOSE WOULD BE CLOSEST TO A
RELEASE SO THAT PEOPLE WITH A
COUPLE OF YEARS ORA YEAR OR
MONTHS.
CAN HAVE SOME TARGETED
INSTRUCTION BEFORE.
OKAY -- I
DON'T THINK YOU'RE PROPOSAL
EXPLAINS THAT GOOD ENOUGH I
THINK. ONE OF ONE OF THE ONE OF
THE THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
IS.
YOU KNOW I ALWAYS I ALWAYS LIKE
TO SEE IF YOU'RE.
IS KIND OF LIKE SPECIAL ED HERE
IS WHAT WE'RE DONE WITH --
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST THE MOST
SEVERE IS NOT NECESSARILY A GOOD
THING TO DO.
A SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE ALLOWED
TO DO IT SO I I I KIND OF HOPE
THAT YOU.
WE'LL THINK ABOUT.
HOW YOU MAKE YOUR PRIORITIES AND
NOT JUST --
HELLO THE MODERATES AND AS
OPPOSED TO SERVE YEARS IN TERMS
OF READING READING DIFFICULTY
THAT'S ALL THE QUESTIONS I HAVE
MANAGER.
THANK YOU CENTER MORE LIKE.
IT SEEMS INTUITIVE THAT --
THEIR READING SKILLS.
I'M.
BUT TO HAVE.
I I DIDN'T.
LIKE SEE A STUDY THAT KIND OF A
FIRM THAT I REMEMBER THERE'S
PROBABLY A LOT OF THEM BUT DO WE
HAVE ANY.
STUDIES THAT SHOW THAT A READING
LITERACY PROGRAM IS USED.
IN A STATE AND HERE WERE THE
RESULTS OVER A PERIOD TIME.
I DON'T HAVE A SPECIFIC STUDY TO
REFERENCE FOR THE LITERACY
PROGRAM BUT I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE NUMBER OF PEER TO PEER
PROGRAMS THAT EXIST OUT THERE --
AND I I BELIEVE THERE'S ONE
STATE THAT ACTUALLY IMPLEMENTS
AN ENTIRE INMATE DRIVEN TEACHING
SYSTEM FROM ACTUAL EDUCATION TO
VOCATIONAL PART OF WHAT WE KNOW
HERE.
IS THE BASE FACT THAT PEOPLE
WITH HIGHER LEVELS OF LITERACY
OR THAT ACHIEVED THAT HIGH
SCHOOL EQUIVALENCY DIPLOMA WILL
DO MUCH BETTER WHEN THEY ARE
RELEASED IN TERMS OF OR SAID
ABOUT THEM WE HAD SOME INITIAL
NUMBERS.
I'M THAT ARE STILL PRELIMINARY
THERE'S A LOT OF DEMOGRAPHICS
THAT HAVE TO BE ANALYZED AROUND
IT BUT FOR THOSE --
PEOPLE THAT WERE RELEASED IN
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN THAT HAD A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR
EQUIVALENT SEE.
THEIR RECIDIVISM ONE YEAR
CONVICTION RATE WAS ABOUT NINE
POINT 5%.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
WHICH IS A TO RELATIONS ONE YOUR
CONVICTION RATE IT'S EIGHTEEN
POINT 3% SO ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT
APPLES TO APPLES THERE'S MORE
THAT HAS TO BE DONE WITH THAT'S
INITIALLY SAYING IS?
THERE'S NEARLY A 50% DROP IN
ACTIONS FOR THOSE THAT HAVE
THOSE HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMAS WORK
OF ONE SEES.
IT'S VERY PRELIMINARY WE NEED TO
DO MORE ABOUT IT BASICALLY
SUPPORTS THE FACT IN THERE'S A
NUMBER OF EDUCATIONAL STUDIES
OUT THERE FROM RAND. TO OTHER
PLACES AS A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA
OR EQUIVALENT SEE THOSE OF THE
WAYS TO TARGET PEOPLE BEFORE THE
RELEASE BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY
GOING TO BE HELPFUL TO THEM.
IF SOMEBODY HAS --
A CVT NEED OR VOCATIONALLY BUT
THEY CAN ACTUALLY READ THAT'S
NOT GONNA HELP THEM AS MUCH SO
REALLY HAVING THIS ACADEMIC
LITERACY SUPPORT IS CRITICAL I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF EVIDENCE
BASED PRINCIPLES.
AND DATA SURROUNDING IT TO SAY
GETTING PEOPLE FOR THIS
EDUCATIONAL LITERACY LEVELS
REALLY IMPORTANT.
SO WHILE YOU'RE ANSWERING CENTER
BELLS QUESTIONS I JUST LOOK UP
ON MY IPHONE BUT CAST.
PROGRAMS ARE STUDIES ROUTE THERE
IN WHAT CAME UP WHEN I KEYED IN
A FEW KEY WORDS.
WAS A A SITE CALLED PRISON
FELLOWSHIP.
WHICH AS A VOLUNTEER PROGRAM
WHERE.
PEOPLE CAN COME AND HELP EACH.
INMATES HOW TO READ I'M JUST
WONDERING DO WE TAP INTO A
VOLUNTEER BASIS SPECIALLY WITH
THE A SENIOR RETIREE POPULATION
IS GROWING.
I KNOW THATWE HAVE A
SUBSTANTIAL NUMBER OF VOLUNTEERS
THAT COME IN BOTH ON THEIR OWN
INTER INNOVATIVE GRANTS.
I DO.
I DON'T KNOW OF ANY OFF THE TOP
MAN BUT I'D BE HAPPY TO GET YOU
SOME INFORMATION ON WHETHER WE
HAVE.
EDUCATIONAL.
HERE STUDENT TUTORS I KNOW THAT
IT HAPPENS I'M JUST YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU GO AND VISIT AN
INSTITUTION OFTEN ARE.
MATERIALS DESCRIBED.
AND NUMBER OF THE VOLUNTARY ON
THE THE VOLUNTEER EDUCATION
PROGRAMS AND ALSO DESCRIBED A
BILL.
WHICH I ESTABLISH THEM UNDER
SENATOR HANCOCK SO THERE ARE I
DON'T KNOW ROBUST.
GREEN I AM [inaudible]
STILL AT CORRECTIONS ONE A ONE
SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IS I'M
TRYING TO LEARN ABOUT HOW MANY
SO WE DO HAVE VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS
IN OUR STATE PRISONS AND
INDIVIDUALS.
SO HOW DO WE MERGE THE
VOLUNTEERS WITH.
THE THIRTY FIVE POSITIONS THAT
YOU'RE.
TRYING TO ADD.
I THINK THIS IS A DISTINCT
PROGRAM BUT THOSE VOLUNTEERS
CREATE A CULTURE THAT WE FULLY
SUPPORT I THINK IT CONTINUES TO
HELP.
THE BASIC CONCEPTS AS WE HAVE IF
WE SAY WE HAVE 62% OF PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT HAVE THEIR HIGH
SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR EQUIVALENCY.
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS THERE IS
ALWAYS ROOM FOR MORE --
AND THERE'S ALWAYS ROOM TO GROW
SO I THINK I'LL GO BACK AND LOOK
AT THESE THESE PROGRAMS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE COMBINING BIRTH
APPROPRIATELY --
BUT THEY REALLY CAN STILL STAND
ON THEIR OWN I BELIEVE AND
ACHIEVE WHAT WE WANT WHICH IS
GETTING PEOPLE HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA OR EQUIVALENT SEE PRIOR
TO RELEASE.
AND THEN.
HOW DO YOU ASKED BECAUSE READING
IS WANTING COMPREHENSION IS
ANOTHER?
IS THIS ORDER.
COME OUT OF THE THE THE READING
HORIZONS PROGRAM DO THEY KIND OF
THE KIND OF GREAT OR ANALYZE HOW.
SOMEONE IS IMPROVING HE'S BEEN.
ON THEIR READING SKILLS IN THE
RETENTION SKILLS.
OUR OUR BASIC ASSESSMENTS ARE
DONE THROUGH OUR TAPING COSTS.
WHICH ARE STANDARDIZED
ASSESSMENTS OUR INSTRUCTORS GIVE
OUT AFTER A CERTAIN NUMBER OF
HOURS OF ACADEMIC PROGRAMMING
BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE CORRECT IN
BOTH READING HORIZONS AND ASKED
TECH -- AS
PEOPLE ANSWER QUESTIONS THEY RE
FOCUS ON THOSE TARGETS BUT THEY
MIGHT HAVE MISSED THINGS OR
OFFER UP SOLUTIONS THANKS TO
FOCUS ON SO ALL OF THE PROGRAMS
THAT WE USE --
GO BACK TO WHAT TARGETED NEEDS
MIGHT BE THERE AND THEN ARE
STANDARDIZED ASSESSMENT THERE
WHAT WE REALLY TRY TO USE IN
TERMS OF GRADE LEVEL GROWTH.
IS THERE A COMPONENT OF SAY
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE IN THIS
OP OR THAT KIND OF HIS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE ALREADY WAY
BEYOND LEVEL WE NEED TO MOVE YOU
UP WITH A HIGHER.
IT WOULD IT WOULD DISPLAY IN OUR
WHERE WE REALLY FOCUSED BUT IF
THEY WERE DOING A SOFTWARE SO
READING HORIZONS FOR INSTANCE IS
USUALLY PEOPLE BETWEEN.
A GRADE LEVEL --
OF ZERO TO FOURTH GRADE AND SO
IT REALLY FOCUSES ON THOSE OF
THOSE LOWER LITERACY LEVELS AND
IF THEY WERE SEEING ACADEMIC
GROWTH --
IMPROVEMENT AFTER A CERTAIN
NUMBER F HOURS THEY WOULD GET
REASSESS THROUGH OUR TABOR COSTS
THIS TEST AND THEN THEY WOULD BE
PLACED INTO A HIGHER LEVEL
PROGRAM BASED ON THAT TEACHER.
REVIEWING BUT THOSE TEST SCORES
AND THEIR ACADEMIC GRASS.
AND THIS VOTE HOW MANY OTHER
PROGRAMS BACK TO ONE A ONE HOW
MANY OTHER PROGRAMS CAN YOU SIGN
UP [inaudible]
FOR THE A WHOLE LOT BUT BASS
FIRE FIRE.
TRAINING.
CAN AND HOW MANY CAN YOU SIGN UP.
FOR ONE I DON'T THINK THERE'S A
LIMIT ON SIGNING UP FOR PROGRAMS
I THINK IT'S MORE ABOUT.
WHAT THE SCHEDULE LOOKS LIKE IN
THE ABILITY FOR THE --
AND MADE ACTUALLY ATTEND A FIRE
CAMP YOU COULD BE IN THAT
PROGRAM AND BE A MAN OR FOR THE
READING.
I IMAGINE THAT THE THE READING
PROGRAM AS WERE ROLLING IT OUT
THAT HAVE TO BE INVOLVED IN
THINGS LOCATED IN THE PRISON --
BUT WE ALSO HAVE OUR OF
VOLUNTARY EDUCATION PROGRAM
WHICH IS ARE ACCREDITED
INSTRUCTORS THAT HELP OUT OF
FIRE CAMPS.
GREAT THANK YOU MANAGER THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORE LACKEY
[inaudible]
SO I'M.
I AM A NUMBER QUESTION FIRST.
ON THE QUESTION THAT SENATOR
BILL ASK AROUND THE CRIMINAL
PERSONALITY THERAPY.
IN OUR OWN.
AND IT YOU DIDN'T SEEM TO KNOW
THIS.
IT INDICATES THAT IN SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN THERE WAS A ESTIMATION
OF ABOUT 41%.
OR FORTY FOUR THOUSAND OFFENDERS
WERE ASSESSED YOU HAVE A
MODERATE TO HIGH NEED FOR
CRIMINAL PERSONALITY THERAPY.
THAT WOULD SEEM TO INDICATE.
THAT THERE'S BEEN WELL PERHAPS
NOT A FULL ON ASSESSMENT OF ALL
INMATES.
SOME LEVEL OF ASSESSMENT OF A
GOOD PROPORTION OF VIDEO DIDN'T
SEEM TO INDICATE THAT.
I MIGHT HAVE I MIGHT HAVE.
NOT BEEN CLEAR ENOUGH.
SO WHEN.
WHEN ANY IN MAY COMES IN TWO THE
DCR THE RECEPTION CENTER AS LONG
AS THEY'RE NOT ONE OF THE
EXCLUSIONARY GREATER THEY WILL
GET A COMPASS ASSESSMENT?
WHICH ASSESSES THEIR DYNAMIC
COMMISSION IT NEEDS ONE OF THOSE
COMPONENTS IS CRIMINAL THINKING
WHAT YOU'RE READING IS PROBABLY --
WHAT THAT IS FROM WHICH IS ABOUT
40% OF THOSE COME INTO CITIES
OUR STATE INSTITUTION THAT ARE
AUTOMATICALLY ASSESSED AS A
MODERATE TO HIGH FOR CRIMINAL?
SO ASA HIGH NEED FOR CRIMINAL
PERSONALITY THERAPY YES.
INTERCHANGEABLE SO SO I'M SORRY
WELL GIVEN THAT.
YOUR PROPOSAL THE MINISTRATIONS
PROPOSAL.
SAYS THAT WE WOULD PROVIDE THIS
THERE BE TO EVERY INMATE WHO WAS
PART OF THIS MENTOR PROGRAM SO
THAT WOULD.
BE INDEPENDENT OF WHETHER THEY
WERE IT MODERATE TO HIGH NEED
[inaudible]
GIVEN THAT.
I MEAN THAT I THINK THE ALEJO'S
POINT THAT THAT DOESN'T MAKE A
LOT OF SENSE.
IS LEGITIMATE WHY WOULDN'T YOU
ONLY REQUIRE THAT FOR THOSE WHO
WERE.
ASSESSED AT MODERATE TO HIGH
NEED.
SO THOSE THAT WERE ASSESSED
MOTOR TINY WILL ALREADY BE A
PART OF THE C. B. T. PROGRAM
WHICH IS.
WHAT WE'RE READING INDICATES NOT
EVERYONE IS RECEIVED THAT SO I
DID SO IN OTHER WORDS YOU CAN'T
PROVIDE IT FOR EVERYBODY AT ONCE?
SO CLEARLY IT'S YOU PROBABLY
HAVE A BACKLOG.
SO WHY WOULD YOU REQUIRE IT. FOR
THOSE IN YOUR MENTOR PROGRAM WHO
ARE NOT ASSESSED AT MODERATE TO
HIGH.
THOSE IN THE PROGRAM THAT WERE
NOT AS FAST AS A MODERATE I NEED
WOULD NOT BE EXPECTED TO TAKE
PART OF THE C. B. T. PROGRAM
THAT EXCESS.
WEIGHT THEY ARE AS PART OF THE
CURRICULUM INSTRUCTION WITH THE
VOLUNTARY EDUCATION.
GOING TO BE TAUGHT CRIMINAL
THINKING OPPONENTS BECAUSE A LOT
OF THE POPULATION THAT THEY MAY
BE INTERACTING WITH HAVE A
CRIMINAL THINKING ASSESSMENT.
SO A LOT OF IT WAS ATTACKED I
WANT TO SAY LIKE A TRAIN THE
TRAINER APPROACH HAVING THEM
UNDERSTAND THOSE CRIMINAL
THINKING BEHAVIORS WILL ALSO
HELP THEM INTERACT WITH POSSIBLY
THE VOLUNTARY STUDENTS.
NOW IF THEY ALREADY ARE SETTLED
IT'S NOT WRITTEN THAT WAY RIGHT
SO YOU NEED TO NOW IF THERE.
I WILL WE WILL CLARIFY BUT THAT
IS NOT THE INTENT OF THE
PROPOSAL.
I'M ALL RIGHT SO NEXT POINT --
BACK TO MISTER SENATOR BELLS
POINTS ABOUT.
AN ADEQUATE ASSESSMENT TO LEARN
HOW TO READ.
IF YOU HAVE ANY OF THESE
UNDERLYING ISSUES OF SAY VISION.
OR SOMETHING ON THE SPECTRUM OF
LEX YES.
WE'RE VARIETY OF OTHER THINGS
THAT.
COULD IMPEDE ONE'S ABILITY TO
READ.
THAT HAS TO BE IDENTIFIED
[inaudible]
BEFORE.
pOUT OF TEN TO ASSIST SOMEONE TO
BE ABLE --
TO LEARN HOW TO READ.
SO IF THAT HASN'T BEEN
IDENTIFIED.
AND WE HAVE MENTORS BRING TO
HELP PEOPLE LEARN HOW TO READ.
WE CAN CREATE A VERY FRUSTRATING
CIRCUMSTANCE BOTH FOR THE INMATE.
WHO IS TRYING TO LEARN HOW TO
READ AND THE AND THE INMATE WAS
MEANT BRING THEM?
IF THAT UNDERLYING SO YOU
DESCRIBE A THING WHERE YOU THE
ASSESSMENT TOOLS CAN DISCOVER
FOR EXAMPLE WHETHER.
YOU SAID TO ME ABOUT RECOGNIZING
NUMERALS FOR TELLING TIME I
THINK WAS WHAT YOU DESCRIBE.
WELL THAT COULD BE IDENTIFIED.
WHAT IF THAT'S SAY ON THE
DYSLEXIC SPARE ROOM?
UNLESS IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT IS
WHY VERSUS JUST THAT.
NO ONE EVER MADE THAT
CORRELATION THE FOR THEN JUST
TRYING TO POINT OUT TO SOMEONE
HITS A NUMBER.
THEY'RE NOT LEARNING.
RIGHT SO WHAT TYPE OF PRE
DIAGNOSIS IS DONE.
SO THAT WE CAN.
ENSURE THAT WHAT EVER.
WE'RE OFFERING TO THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE NOT YET AT NINETY THREE
READING LEVELS [inaudible]
WORKS.
SO I I WILL ANSWER IN
GENERALITIES AND I WILL GIVE YOU
MORE SPECIFIC INFORMATION THERE
ARE ASSESSMENT THEY'RE DONE BY
MEDICAL UP FRONT THIS SIZE.
I PEOPLE'S RELIABLE THAT THAT
HAPPENS AND OUR TEACHERS USE
THAT INFORMATION ADDITIONALLY.
ALL OF OUR ACCREDITED TEACHERS
ARE TRAINED TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
ISSUES NOW THEY'RE IN THEIR
INCLUDED IN THE ACADEMIC
PROGRESS REPORTS AN ACADEMIC
NOTES FOR THE STUDENT IN OUR
SYSTEM.
I'LL GET MORE INFORMATION ON
WHAT EXACTLY THAT TRAINING LOOKS
LIKE BUT WE DO HAVE ALL OF OUR
TEACHERS ARE CREDITED AND THEY
ARE ON ABLE TO DISCERN SOME OF
THOSE THINGS THAT YOU THAT'S
REFERENCE SO THAT.
THEY CAN MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE
FACILITATING THE RIGHT
STRUCTURED ENVIRONMENT AND
LEARNING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
STUDENT. FOR THE MENTOR FOR OFF
FOR EVERYBODY THAT THEY'RE
INTERACTING WITH SO THEY WOULD
ALREADY HAVE BEEN.
IN.
PLANS TO LAY OUT THE TEACHER
WOULD BE WORKING DIRECTLY WITH
THOSE MENTORS WHO ARE LOOK
WORKING WITH THE MENTEES AND THE
TEACHER WOULD HAVE ACCESS TO ALL
OF THOSE MEN TEASE.
THOSE STUDENT RECORDS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RECOGNIZING ANY OF
THOSE NEEDS YOUR AVAILABLE OR
THAT THEY MIGHT NEED TO MAKE UP
[inaudible]
FOR I'M.
THE THE OTHER.
ANOTHER POINT THAT I WANTED.
TO YES I KNOW.
BUT IN ORDER IS WE DIDN'T GET
THE YEAH.
OKAY.
I'M.
BERMAN FINANCE DID YOU HAVE ANY
THING YOU ONE DAD.
WHICH MARIN APARTMENT FINANCE
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE SEE THIS AS
A COST EFFECTIVE WAY TO REACH A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF INMATES.
ON THE LA --
MAN MENTIONED A RAMP UP PERIOD
AND BECAUSE OF THE SIGNIFICANT
RAMP UP HERE IT IS GOING TO TAKE
TIME TO ROLL THE PROGRAM OUT WE
THINK PILOTING IT WILL JUST TO
LIKE TO AVOID --
ALL RIGHT I'M.
I WILL SEE IF CENTER MORE LIKE
WHAT.
MAYBE THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
IS THERE A WAY TO QUANTIFY.
I GOT.
THE RESULTS.
IMPROVE READING SKILLS IS THERE
ARE SOME.
THROUGH SOME WAY THAT THE
RECIDIVISM GOES DOWN WHICH THEN
THEREFORE RESULTS IN LAST.
INCARCERATION WHICH TRANSLATES
INTO THE FOLLOWING DOLLARS SO
THAT WERE SPENDING A DIME TO
MAKE A QUARTER.
WE HAVE ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WELL.
WE'VE THE DEPARTMENT TWENTY
COLLECTING A NUMBER OF THOSE --
OUTCOME MEASURES WE CAN SEE THE
EFFECT OF THE PROGRAM ON
LITERACY RATES AND THEN WE CAN --
EXTRAPOLATE YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
MIGHT MEAN FOR RECIDIVISM BUT
THAT'S GONNA TAKE SOME TIME TO
DO THAT EVALUATION AND THEN.
WE COULD TRANSLATE THAT INTO A
HYPOTHETICAL A DOLLAR AMOUNT
BASED ON HOW MUCH WE THINK THIS
WILL IMPACT RECIDIVISM BUT YES
THAT IS THE IDEA THAT THIS WILL --
GET A BIG BANG FOR OUR BUCK IN
TERMS OF REDUCING RECIDIVISM
QUICKLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
CENTRE BELL.
I JUST HAD ANOTHER QUESTION --
WE HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
INCARCERATED THAT ARE --
THEIR ENGLISH.
IS NOT YOUR MAIN LANGUAGE AND I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT --
NATURE OF YOUR PROGRAM RELATIVE
TO NON ENGLISH SPEAKING.
INMATES AND WHETHER OR NOT
[inaudible]
THE SAME.
LEVEL OF PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO
PLAY APPLY TO THEM VERSUS
ENGLISH SPEAKING.
WHAT IS THE PLAN FOR THIS
PROGRAM FOR THE?
THE BILINGUAL --
OR ARE THEY ARE NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING OF SAID NON ENGLISH
SPEAKING [inaudible]
IMAGE.
OUR OFFICE OF CORRECTIONAL
EDUCATION --
RIGHT NOW AT THE HIGHEST LEVEL
THERE'S THERE'S NOT BEEN A
DIAGNOSTIC TEST THAT ASSESSES
PEOPLES --
SECONDARY LANGUAGE LEVEL SO
RIGHT NOW WE LOOK AT THOSE
READING BELOW THE FOURTH GRADE
LEVEL FOR THEIR PRIMARY LANGUAGE
IS NOT ENGLISH.
AND THERE'S ABOUT SIX THOUSAND
OF THOSE RIGHT NOW.
THE THE SECOND PIECE OF THAT IS
WE ARE --
PROPOSING AND IMPLEMENTING A
TAPE CLASS THE EXAM WHICH
FOCUSES ON YES CELL AND THEY'LL
BE ABLE TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND
NOW IN TERMS OF PARTICIPATING IN
THIS.
IF THERE'S A VOLUNTARY NATURE
THAT THEIR PARTY FOR OUR
TEACHERS WILL BE WORKING TO FIND
THE SOLUTIONS FOR THOSE STUDENTS
TO BEST FACILITATE --
THAT INSTRUCTION THAT'S THE IDEA
OF BEING REALLY COLLABORATIVE
WITH THESE VOLUNTARY EDUCATION
MENTORS AND CONSTRUCTION --
THAT'S HAPPENING ALREADY IN THE
FIELD TO MAKE SURE THAT THEIR
TAG TO THE RIGHT MENTOR TIED TO
THE RIGHT TEACHER.
BUT WE ARE ALSO IMPLEMENTING
THAT TAPE CLASSY EXAMPLE.
TO BETTER HELP US ASSESS WHO HAS
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE
ISSUES.
WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE ENGLISH AS A SECOND
LANGUAGE AT ALL AGES?
THEY DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH. FOR
THOSE -- I
DON'T I HAVE TO GO BACK AND AND
SEE WELL I JUST SAY YOUR PROGRAM
DOES NOT DESCRIBE.
THE ISSUE ADEQUATELY I'D LIKE TO
HAVE IT.
DESCRIBE A LITTLE MORE CLEARLY
SO THAT WE CAN.
BE SURE THAT.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT THEIR
LANGUAGES THERE ARE THE PROGRAM
WILL TREAT THEM EQUALLY
[inaudible]
SELECT.
WERE ALL LANGUAGES.
THE DIFFERENT LANGUAGES AFTER
[inaudible]
THE GUM.
DO YOU HAVE AN IDEA OF HOW MANY
INMATES IN OUR SYSTEM.
DON'T SPEAK ENGLISH AT ALL.
I DO NOT HAVE THAT THE TOP I
DON'T KNOW MEANS OF CAN MAYBE
TELL US OF THEY THINK IN TERMS
OF LEARNING I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT.
WE WANT TO HAVE THE ABILITY TO
LEARN FOR EVERYBODY NOT JUST.
THE EXISTING ENGLISH.
I THANK YOU SENATOR OVER FOR ASK
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT --
I ATE A I CAN'T SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUES BUT I WANTED --
TO INDICATE THAT MY QUESTIONS
WEREN'T NECESSARILY.
I DON'T WANT THEM TRIGGERED THAT
I WOULD OPPOSE THIS PROGRAM BUT
RATHER I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
I DON'T WANT TO SET UP A
SITUATION WHERE EITHER THE
MENTOR OR THE INMATE IS
[inaudible]
THERE'S A THAT WE CREATED MORE
FRUSTRATION AND LESS SUCCESS
BECAUSE WE'VE NOT DONE
ASSESSMENTS PROPERLY --
WE HAVEN'T AND THE TRAINING.
I MEAN I THINK THAT.
NOW.
THAT WE AS A STATE UNDERSTAND
THAT REHABILITATION IS AN
ESSENTIAL THE CENTRAL COMPONENT
OF OUR SEIZE YOUR SYSTEM.
MUCH MORE ROBUST PROGRAMS.
IN LITERACY AND EDUCATION.
IN -- ROB
TRAINING IN IN ALL IN MANY MANY
ASPECTS OF THINGS THAT SOME OF
US MAY HAVE.
YOU KNOW BEEN FORTUNATE ENOUGH
TO ACQUIRE EARLIER IN OUR LIFE.
BUT YOU KNOW THOSE THOSE MUST BE
VERY ROBUST PART OF OUR ENTIRE
CORRECTION SYSTEM AND THEY STILL
AS WE KNOW OR NOT WE'VE MADE.
WE'VE MADE PROGRESS THERE OR
SOMETHING BUT IT'S NOT YET REAL
ROBUST.
AND WE CERTAINLY WANT TO BE BUT
WE ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YES WE AS WE EXPAND PROGRAMS AT
THEIR IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE.
POSSIBLE SO I WANT TO PUT THAT
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE COMMENT.
ANYONE ON THIS SIDE OF OKAY.
SEEING NONE.
WE WILL --
MOVE ONWERE NOT ACTING ON THE
ITEMS THAT WILL OFFICE TO GET
MORE INFORMATION FOR WHEN WE
COME BACK --
WHEN WE VISITED AGAIN?
AND ACT ON THE B. C. P..
SO THE NEXT ITEM THAT WILL NOW
MOVE TO IS OUR INFORMATIONAL
PANEL.
ON WHAT WE CALL THE PRISONS
COMMUNITY PIPELINE WE CALLED IT
THAT BECAUSE AS I POINTED OUT --
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OUR FOLKS
THAT ARE.
INCARCERATED.
WILL BE RETURNING HOME.
AND SO.
WHAT WHAT IS THE STATUS NOW IN
THIS OF COURSE IS NAP SHOT?
THIS IS NOT TO BE UNDERSTOOD AS
YOU KNOW EXHAUSTIVE RESEARCH OR
EXHAUSTIVE.
OVERVIEW OF EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENING WITHIN OUR SYSTEM BUT
RATHER.
IT IT IT'S UP THE PURPOSE OF
THIS INFORMATIONAL PANELISTS TO
GIVE US SOME SENSE.
OF THE VALUE NON VALUE PRESENTS
NON PRESENCE AND NEED --
FOR THINGS WITHIN OUR STATE
FACILITIES TO HELP US.
ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A HEALTHY.
PRISON TO COMMUNITY PIPELINE SO
I'D LIKE TO HAVE THE SPEAKERS
COME TO THE TABLE.
WE HAVE OUR NINE CON WHO IS THE
CO FOUNDER OF RESTORE JUSTICE
AND WHO WAS ALSO FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PERSON.
HAVE KEITH WHAT LEE WHO IS THE
FOUNDER AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF UNCOMMON Là.
UNCOMMON Là PROVIDE --
LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO FOLKS.
BEFORE AND DURING THEIR WHEN
THEY'RE PRESENTED BEFORE THE
PAROLE BOARD AND COMMON LAW MAY
DO ADDITIONAL THINGS BUT THAT IS
THE WHAT I AM MOST FAMILIAR WITH --
BUT AS A RESULT OF PROVIDE ALL
TO FOLKS BEFORE THEY GO TO THE
PRO BOARD.
ON THE FOLKS THAT WORK WITH
UNCOMMON Là OBVIOUSLY HAVE A
LOT OF REACTION WITH PEOPLE
WITHIN OUR INCARCERATED SYSTEM.
SO.
I DON'T KNOW WHICH ONE OF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN [inaudible]
YOUR PREFERENCES.
GOOD MORNING MADAM WHAT LIKE.
I'LL I'LL START US OFF HERE --
I AM KEITH WILEY FROM ON COMMON
LAW AND WHAT WE DO.
PROVIDE LEGAL ASSISTANCE TO
PEOPLE GOING THROUGH OUR
DISCRETIONARY PAROLE PROCESS
WHICH RIGHT NOW ACTUALLY IMPACTS.
MORE THAN HALF OF ALL CALIFORNIA
PRISONERS.
MOST OF WHAT WE DO IS LONG
BEFORE SOMEONE APPEARS BEFORE
THE PAROLE BOARDS AND IN THE WAY
OF COUNSELING --
AND HELPING TO GUIDE THEIR THEIR
PUNIC EFFORTS INSIDE AND MR OILY
BEFORE YOU GO COULD YOU --
JUST SAY LITTLE MORE ABOUT WE'RE
ON COMING LAWS BASED AND AND
RIGHT AND THEN.
DESCRIBE IT'S OUR OFFICE IS IN
OAKLAND.
AND WE'RE A NONPROFIT --
THAT WE'VE BEEN IN BUSINESS.
FOR ALMOST THIRTEEN YEARS NOW.
WE HAVE WORKED WITH OF THEM.
THE HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE GOING THROUGH THIS
DISCRETION APRIL PROCESS.
BOTH IN --
INDIVIDUAL MATTERS REPRESENTING
THEM INDIVIDUALLY AND IN CLASS
ACTION LAWSUITS THAT WE HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY LITIGATED AGAINST.
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
INCLUDING THE WE'RE NO LONGER
INVOLVED IN LITIGATION AT THIS
POINT --
THAT THAT THAT HAS BEEN WRAPPED
UP WHICH I THINK HAS HELPED --
OPEN UP DIALOGUE FRANKLY BETWEEN
US AND THE BOARD OF PAROLE
HEARINGS AS WE HAVE.
GAINED A LOT OF PERSPECTIVE.
ARM ABOUT HOW.
THE PROBOARDS VIEWED BY PEOPLE
WHO ARE INSIDE --
AND I THINK THAT CAN INFORM
CONVERSATION BETWEEN US AND THE
BOARD ADMINISTRATION AND AND AS
LONG AS THE ADMINISTRATION IS
INCLUDED.
OF MISS SHAFER WHO'S THE CURRENT
EXECUTIVE OFFICER --
WE'VE NOTICED THE A CHANGE IN
HOW THEY OPERATE IN TERMS OF
BEING MORE TRANSPARENT AND
WILLING TO FIND WAYS --
TO REALLY TACKLE SOME REALLY
DIFFICULT TIME --
SO I APPRECIATE HER --
OPENNESS TO TO OUR OUR INPUT --
AND WORKING WITH US.
THE UNCOMMON Là STARTED WHERE
IN YOUR STAFF FOR MOSTLY WHAT.
WE OWE.
WELL I FOUNDED IN --
TWO THOUSAND SIX IN OAKLAND AND
WE ARE STAFF WE HAVE A SMALL
STAFF OF SIX PEOPLE.
N..
WE HAVE LAWYERS SOCIAL WORKERS --
WE HAVE --
PEOPLE FORMING CARS RATED WHO
WORK WITH US AND DO THE SAME
KIND OF COUNSELING AND SUPPORT
THAT WE THAT THE REST OF THE
TEAM DOES.
WE ALSO HAVE ABOUT TWO DOZEN --
VOLUNTEERS IT'S THE ONLY WAY WE
CAN REACH AS MANY AS WE DO --
AND THEY ARE MADE UP OF LAWYERS
A OTHER THERAPISTS --
AND TOGETHER WE WE REACH --
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE WE'VE HAD --
A COUPLE HUNDRED OF OUR CLIENTS.
WHO WERE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES
BE RELEASED THROUGH THE
DISCRETIONARY PROBOSCIS AND WE?
WE DO -- YOU
KNOW WE'RE VERY PROUD OF THAT WE
HAVE A RECIDIVISM RATE BELOW 1% --
SO WE WE FOUND THAT.
WHAT WE DO SEEM TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE --
AND WE'RE WE'RE REALLY EAGER --
TO CONTINUE REGION AS MANY AS WE
CAN -- WITH
TO MAKE THIS MODEL AVAILABLE TO
A LOT MORE PEOPLE --
I'D I PERSONALLY --
A FIRST WAS A A I'M HONORED TO
BE SAID HERE NEXT TO MISTER KHAN
BECAUSE I THINK IN A LOT OF WAYS
THE PERSPECTIVE HE CAN PROVIDE
IS ONE THAT IS JUST --
ONE MOST OF US DON'T HEAR OFTEN
ENOUGH AND AND WILL PLAY A
REALLY SIGNIFICANT ROLE IN
SHAPING --
THE PROGRAMMATIC OFFERINGS
WITHIN INSTITUTIONS GOING
FORWARD --
AND I KNOW THAT WITH THE LAST
TIME I SAW HIM HE WAS IN SAN
QUENTIN.
ALSO THERE'S THE MUCH BETTER
BLUE ON HIM I WILL SAY --
IN.
AND I THINK BECAUSE HE
REPRESENTS WHAT'S POSSIBLE WEN
PEOPLE ARE BY THE OPPORTUNITY IN
THE SUPPORT --
BE SUCCESSFUL --
I MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCE --
DOES HELP ME BE HERE --
AND MY IN WITHIN MY OWN FAMILY
I'VE SEEN THE THE MULTI
GENERATIONAL IMPACT OF
UNRESOLVED TRAUMA OF
INCARCERATION.
OUR END RELEASE WITHOUT SOME KEY
SUPPORTS BEING IN PLACE.
MY OWN SISTER SPENT ABOUT.
MOST OF TWENTY YEARS IN JAILS
AND PRISONS GLAZER PRETTY LONG
STRETCHES AND WHEN SHE WOULD
COME HOME.
SHE WOULDN'T HAVE ANY BETTER
SENSE OF HOW SHE ENDED UP THERE.
AND SHE DID WHEN SHE WENT.
THERE WAS NO COUNSELING THOSE
THERAPY NO SUPPORT FOR HER TO
ANSWER THE BASIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
HOW.
HER OWN CHILDHOOD.
EXPERIENCES --
IMPACT HER DECISIONS IN OUR
ACTIONS --
AND IT TOOK ME SHE WAS SHE WAS --
IN THE AND FORTIES BEFORE SHE
REALLY CONNECTED TO SOME WORK I
WAS DOING.
AND SO I I STE I KNOW WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE AND I I SEE HOW THAT
IMPACTS HER KIDS AND HER ABILITY
TO COMMUNICATE WITH THEIR KIDS.
AND SO A LOT OF OUR WORK IS
FOCUSED ON REALLY PROVIDING THE
KIND OF COUNSELING AND AND
SUPPORT THAT THAT SHE NEVER HAD.
AND I FIND THAT IT'S IT'S IT'S
IT'S SO MUCH NEEDED INSIDE THE
INSTITUTION OF PEOPLE REALLY
HUNGRY.
FOR I WILL SAY THE WHAT I FOUND
IS THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
OUT OF PRISON --
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO.
ARE COMING FROM LIFE SENTENCES
AND AND AND AND FOCUS ON A
POPULATION. FOR THIS
CONVERSATION ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THE WORK THEY HAVE TO DO.
IN ORDER TO DEMONSTRATE TO THE
PAROLE BOARD THERE NO LONGER WAS
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
IS WORK THAT NOBODY ELSE HAS TO
DO.
THEY HAVE.
TO FIGURE OUT HOW THEIR OWN
ADVERSE CHILDHOOD EXPERIENCES
IMPACT THEIR DECISIONS AND
ACTIONS.
LED TO LET THEM HURT THEMSELVES
AND OTHERS IF YOU DON'T RESOLVE
THOSE THINGS WHILE THEY'RE IN
PRISON THEY CAN'T COME HOME.
SO WHEN THEY DO COME HOME HAVING
DONE THAT WORK.
I THINK THEY ARE THE ARE THE KEY.
TO REALLY DISRUPTING VIOLENCE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES --
THEY PLAY REALLY CRITICAL ROLE
AND THERE AREN'T ENOUGH
OPPORTUNITIES WITHIN THE
EMPLOYMENT ACT PASSED.
AND EVEN MOTHER INSIDE THE
PRISON.
THEY PLAY SUCH A KEY ROLE.
IN --
PROVIDING MENTOR SHIP GUIDANCE
SUPPORT TO OTHER PEOPLE TRYING
TO TRAIN TRYING TO TRAVEL THE
SAME ROUTE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THE SAME ANSWERS TO THOSE
QUESTIONS.
AND SO I THINK IT'S A GREAT --
IS A GREAT POTENTIAL IN THIS
THINGS INSIDE AND OUTSIDE THE
PRESENCE.
HAVING --
WORK WITH SO MANY PEOPLE INSIDE
THE PRISON OF IDENTIFIED.
SOME SOME ASPECTS OF SOME OF THE
BETTER --
PROGRAMS INSIDE INSTITUTIONS --
AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH WITH --
WITH THIS COMMITTEE. ONE OF THE
THE KEY PIECES THAT WE FIND IS
THAT -- WHEN
WE START A CONVERSATION WITH
SOMEONE?
YOU KNOW THE THE WORST CHILD
EXPERIENCING A REMEMBER.
AND THEY MAY START TO OPEN UP
ABOUT THAT.
AND WE STE MAY SPEND OUR COUPLE
HOURS WITH THEM AND THEN I GO
BACK TO MY OFFICE.
AND THEN THERE LEFT IN THE
PRISON.
WHERE THEY HAVE A GREAT A
SUCCESS IS WHERE THEY CAN
CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION WITH
THE COMMUNITY?
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION THAT
SUPPORTS THAT INQUIRY.
GIVES THEM THE SPACE TO BE
VULNERABLE TO TALK ABOUT THOSE
THINGS SUPPORTS THEM DOESN'T
JUDGE THEM DOESN'T SHARE THAT
INFORMATION OUTSIDE OF THE ART.
OF THOSE THE COMMUNITIES THAT
SEEM TO MAKE THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IN THOSE THE ONES
THAT -- THEY
GO BEYOND --
THINGS LIKE ALCOHOLICS ANONYMOUS
AND NARCOTICS.
ANONYMOUS WHICH SIDE THE PRISONS
ARE ANYTHING BUT ANONYMOUS --
N..
IN AND THEY GO INTO THESE THAT
THE FEW PROGRAMS THAT MANY OF
UNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS --
BUT THE ONES THAT DO THIS DEEPER
DEEPER DIVE INTO SOMEONE'S HOME.
HISTORY AND AND AND LIFE
EXPERIENCES --
BUT I FOUND THAT THOSE THAT
THOSE PRISONS THAT HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY.
WHERE THIS WHAT CAN HAPPEN?
IS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE THE
GREATEST SUCCESS --
IN THERE AREN'T ENOUGH OF THOSE --
THE THE ONE WITH SOMETIMES THINK
ABOUT IN TERMS OF MASLOW
HIERARCHY OF NEEDS.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU WHEN YOU WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THAT AT THE BASIC AT
THE BOTTOM LEVELS THERE'S JUST
BASIC.
BASIC NEEDS OF OUR FOOD SHELTER
WATER SAFETY.
YOU CAN'T REALLY THINK ABOUT
MUCH ELSE IF YOU DON'T HAVE
THOSE THINGS HANDLED.
N. AT THE HIGH SECURITY LEVEL
PRISONS AND THOSE THAT DON'T
HAVE A THERAPEUTIC COMMUNITY.
THE THE THE MAIN FOCUS IS NOT
OUR SURVIVE TODAY.
A YOU CAN'T THINK BEYOND HOW TO
MY CHILDHOOD IMPACT MY DECISION
YOU DON'T GET TO THAT POINT.
SO -- YOU
GOTTA HAVE YOU GOTTA BE IN A
SAFE PLACE AND AND THAT TAKES.
ON A SHARED AGREEMENT I THINK.
AMONG THE PEOPLE INCARCERATED
AND THE STAFF AND ADMINISTRATION.
THAT THIS IS WHAT WE'RE HERE.
FOR TO DO THIS WORK WE'RE NOT
JUST HERE TO WAREHOUSE
AND WE'RE NOT JUST HERE TO PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK.
WE HERE TO FIGURE OUT HOW WE
ENDED UP HERE AND HOW TO GET
OURSELVES OUT.
AND I THINK WHERE YOU SEE THESE
THESE POCKETS EXIST LIKE THE SAN
QUENTIN'S.
THERE ARE MANY OF IT'S WHERE
THERE'S A SHARED AGREEMENT THIS
IS THE WORK WE'RE HERE TO DO.
AND WERE SUPPORTED BY THE
ADMINISTRATION SUPPORT BY THE
STAFF AND PEOPLE WERE
INCARCERATED THERE READ YES THIS
IS WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR WE'RE
GONNA DO THIS WRK --
SO ONCE YOU HAVE THE SAFETY
PIECE WE'RE NOT HERE JUST --
TO TO YOU KNOW COMPETE --
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT EACH OTHER
THEN YOU COULD DO THAT WORK.
I'M.
SO THAT THE WITHIN THOSE SPACES
THEY'RE ABLE TO EXPLORE THEIR
CRIME THE ONLY WILL ABLE TO CRY.
THEY'RE ABLE TO BE TO TRUST THAT
THE INFORMATION IS HERE WILL NOT
MAKE IT OUT TO THE YARD WHICH
COULD JEOPARDIZE THEIR SAFETY
AND THE SAFETY OF OTHERS --
IN ONE OF THE OTHER KEY PONENS
CAM COMPONENTS ARE JUST TOUCH
BRIEFLY IS.
THAT THEY ARE OFTEN GUIDED BY
DRIVEN BY --
PEER MENTOR TYPE RELATIONSHIPS
PEOPLE WHO'VE GONE THROUGH THE
PROGRAM --
FIGURE THEMSELVES OUT.
DEVELOP CERTAIN SOARING KEY
COPING SKILLS THAT THEY'VE AND
SHARE WITH OTHERS AND MEN
TOWARDS THEIR OWN.
JOURNEY --
THOSE THOSE FOLKS IN OFTEN THERE
YOU KNOW.
LIFE IS DO THAT FOR OTHER LIFE
IS THE DOOR FOR FOR NON LIFE IS
ALSO.
THAT IT'S SUCH A KEY COMPONENT
THAT IF YOU HAVE A CORE GROUP OF
PEOPLE.
WHO HAVE THOSE BASIC SKILLS IN
US THEY'RE PRETTY COMBINED WHERE
THEY CAN SHARE THOSE WITH OTHER
PEOPLE IN THE STATE?
IT MAKES A HUGE IMPACT GIVE
PEOPLE THE THE THE HOPE THAT
THAT THEY CAN GET THEMSELVES UP
PRISON AND A PATHWAY TO ACTUALLY
DO THAT.
THAT'S BEEN MY EXPERIENCE.
I'M I'M REALLY EAGER TO HEAR
WHAT A NON AS A SAY HAVE BEEN ON
THE OTHER SIDE OF THOSE
EXPERIENCES BUT BUT I'LL BE
HAPPY IT ALSO ANSWERED QUESTIONS.
GO THROUGH.
TIME FOR ME SEE WHETHER THERE IS
ANY QUESTION EITHER CENTER MORE
LOCKER SENATOR PAUL WANTS TO
DIRECT PARTICULAR TO MISTER --
LIGHTLY BEFORE WE HEAR FROM A
NINE OKAY BUT CENTER MORE LIKE.
IT'S UP TO YOU.
MISTER WILEY YOU TO ME THAT IF
THE TIMES SO MAYBE YOU COULD
GIVE ME.
BUT WHAT IS.
HAPPENING IN YOUR CHILDHOOD YEAH.
COULD YOU GIVE ME.
IT'S OBVIOUS ON ITEMS THE JUST
ONE EXAMPLE OF BUT AT BRINGS UP
CHORE --
WHEN IT COMES TO MIND IS --
THE PROBLEM WITH THIS WORK ONE
OF MANY PROBLEMS AS I HAVE A LOT
OF STORIES.
I'LL TRY TO THE TO NOT GO DO ONE
ALONG WAS BUT WELL I'LL I'LL
GIVE YOU A SORT OF A GENERAL
EXAMPLE.
A LOT OF THE PEOPLE I'VE WORKED
WITH [inaudible]
WHO --
COMMITTED VIOLENT CRIMES WEATHER
WAS GANG RELATED OF ANGER
RELATED OTHER ISSUES --
A VERY HIGH PERCENTAGE --
HAD AT THE HEAD SORT OF THE CITY
THIS IS THE FOLLOWING SCENARIO
PLAY OUT.
THE HAD A RUN IN AT SCHOOL OR
SOMEONE TO BIKE OR TOOK THEIR
PROPERTY.
THEY CAME HOME CRYING ABOUT IT.
AND THEIR PARENTS SAID IF YOU
DON'T GO BACK.
DOWN THERE GET THAT BY.
AND COME BACK HERE THEY DON'T
COME BACK.
OR WHEN YOU COME BACK I'M GONNA
GIVE YOUR WORDS BE THAN THEY DID.
SO THEY THEY WERE TOLD IN NO
UNCERTAIN TERMS YOU HAVE TO USE
VIOLENCE. TO SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
AND YOU BETTER LEARN THAT NOW.
OR I'LL TEACH YOU THE HARD WAY.
IT'S A VERY COMMON LESSEN THAT
PEOPLE GET SO THE WHEN YOU SEE
SOMEONE WHO'S AGE SIXTEEN OR
EIGHTEEN AND THEIR FIRST
RESPONSE TO BEING CHALLENGED IN
SOME WAY IS TO USE VIOLENCE IT'S
NOT A MYSTERY HOW THAT HAPPENED.
BUT THEY OFTEN HAVE NEVER ASK
THEMSELVES.
AND I'VE NEVER HAD A SUPPORTIVE
COMMUNITY TO FIGURE THAT OUT HOW
THEY HOW THEY DEVELOP THAT AS
THE RESPONSE TO THE CHALLENGER
OR OR STRESS THAT'S JUST ONE
EXAMPLE BUT IT'S IT'S ONE THAT
SHOWS UP IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
SCENARIOS IN THE CASE THAT WE
DEAL WITH.
THANK YOU YOU ALSO MENTIONED YOU
HAD A 1%.
FAILURE RATE IS AT YES THE
RECIDIVISM RATE FOR PEOPLE WE
WORK WITH --
WHO'VE GOTTEN OUT.
IS BELOW 1%. 99% NEVER COMMIT
ANOTHER CRIME RIGHT.
HOW MANY CLIENTS HAVE YOU HAD
OVER THE THIRTEEN YEARS YOU'VE
BEEN ALL CLIENTS OF OF HAD IT
WELL BECAUSE I REPRESENT THEM IN
A LOT OF DIFFERENT CAPACITIES?
OF THOSE THOSE ARE OUT OF THE
NOW 200- AND TWELVE LICENSE
CLIENTS I'VE HAD RELEASED FROM
PRISON --
ARE A WIN WE WE GO TO ROADS AND
REPRESENT THE MEN PAROLE
HEARINGS WE ALSO DO WORKSHOPS
FOR LARGER GROUPS OF PEOPLE WE
DO.
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE SORT OF
CONSULTATIONS TO GIVE THEM
ADVICE AND HERE'S HOW YOU CAN
IMPROVE YOUR CHANCES NEXT TIME
YOU GO.
EVEN IF WE'RE NOT REPRESENT
BECAUSE SUCH A SMALL GROUP WE
CAN REACH EVERYBODY.
AND BUT BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE
WHAT WE DO EAGER TO FIND WAYS TO
HELP OTHER PEOPLE TRAIN PEOPLE
INSIDE INSTITUTIONS TO DO THE
WORK WE'RE DOING WHICH WE THINK
IS THE MODEL THAT COULD.
CAN EXPAND THE REACH OF WHAT WE
DO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR ALL RIGHT WE WILL M. HERE
FROM ADEN AND CON NOW.
AND PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU YES --
MY NAME IS A NON KHAN --
I'M REPRESENTING RESTORE JUSTICE
WHICH I'M A CO FOUNDER AND
CURRENTLY A CO DIRECTOR OF AND
FIRST I WANT TO THANK MADAM
CHAIR FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THE RARE OPPORTUNITY --
AND I APPRECIATE IN AUSTIN ONE
THINK THE STAFF TO HELP ALONG
SIDE -- WITH
THIS OPPORTUNITY FOR ME --
ALSO WON SAID I ALSO FEEL THE
SAME WAY NEXT TO YOU --
AND YOU'RE TO IS NOT TO THE OF
AND SO I THINK THAT.
THE RASON --
WALKING OVER BACKGROUND MYSELF
I'M A COMMITTED A CRIME AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN IN WHAT SENSE IS
THIS ONE FIVE YEARS TO LIFE --
THREE MONTHS AGO ON CHRISTMAS
EVE GOVERNOR BROWN COMMUTING MY
SENTENCE.
I WAS BLESSED TO HAVE RECEIVED
THAT -- AND
FORTUNATELY SENATE BILL FOURTEEN
THIRTY SEVEN PASSED IN AUGUST
AND IN JANUARY WHEN INTO EFFECT.
WHICH RELEASED ME ON JANUARY.
SO I'VE BEEN --
I SERVE SIXTEEN YEARS AND I'VE
BEEN OUT TWO MONTHS NOW.
I'M THE REASON I'M HERE IS
BECAUSE I READ THE AUDIT.
A POWER THROUGH IT.
AND I SAW SOME.
ALSO A LOT OF THINGS IN THERE
THAT WERE LEFT OUT IN MY OPINION
BASED ON MY PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
OF ATTENDING A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS I'M ATTENDED MULTIPLE
SELF OGUZ REBUILT TO THE
PROGRAMS.
AND THERE WAS ALSO A COUPLE OF
DISTINCTIONS.
IN MY OPINION THAT WERE
COMPLETELY LEFT OUT --
THE COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION
GROUPS VERSES THE THE CDC ARE
RAN PROGRAMS --
IS A BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN IT
TALKS ABOUT.
IN TERMS OF CULTURE AND WHAT
THAT MEANS FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IN TERMS OF TRUST --
AND ALSO ANYTIME I BELIEVE WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT RECIDIVISM --
CAN'T MAKE RECIDIVISM RATES
UNLESS YOU TALK ABOUT --
AGAIN IN MY OPINION HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT BECAUSE I BELIEVE
THOSE THE TWO HIGHEST.
REASONS WHY PEOPLE COME BACK
FROM LAST ONE OF THE STUDIES ARE
READY SAID.82% OF INCARCERATED
PEOPLE COME BACK WITHIN THE
FIRST YEAR.
DIRECTLY LINKED TO HOUSING AND
EMPLOYMENT.
AND SO WHEN I SAW THAT IT WAS
LINKED TO THOSE POOR CBT
PROGRAMS COGNITIVE OR THERAPY
PROGRAMS.
EVER BEEN A SET IN THE AUDIT.
I FEEL LIKE THAT WAS FAILED.
IN.
I HAVE I CAN SPEAK A LOT MORE ON
THAT BUT I THINK --
ARE OPEN TO QUESTIONS THE
MEASURE ACTUALLY WORKS
[inaudible]
I'M.
SINCE YOU OBVIOUSLY.
PARTICIPATED IN.
A VARIETY OF WHAT CDC ARE
CONSIDERED TO BE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS CAN YOU JUST SHARE SOME
PERSPECTIVES ON THAT --
AGAIN KNOWING THAT THIS IS.
YOU'RE SHARING YOUR PERSPECTIVES.
BUT I THINK IT MIGHT BE HELPFUL.
I THINK --
WHEN I WANT TO START WITH --
WE TALK ABOUT.
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY I
THINK WHAT IT DOES WHAT
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY AND
I'M NOT I DON'T BELIEVE THAT IT.
A RIGHT OR WRONG WAY BUT I THINK
WHAT IT DOES IS IS AND PRESSES --
THE IMMEDIATE PROBLEM MEANING --
OKAY WHY AM I THINKING LIKE AS I
HEARD THAT I'M CRIMINAL THINKING
CRIMINAL THINKING A LOT AND IT
KIND OF MADE ME.
THINK LIKE WHAT DOES THAT
ACTUALLY MEAN AM I SUPPOSED TO
STOP.
THINKING CRIM CRIMINALLY NOW --
AND AND OVERCOME THAT QUOTE
UNQUOTE ISSUE THAT'S WITHIN ME.
AND A REALLY IN TERMS OF
UNDERSTANDING TRAUMA AND PAIN
AND HOW.
EXAMPLE I ALWAYS LIKE TO USE IS
I WENT FROM MY EIGHT YEAR OLD
LITTLE LEAGUE BASEBALL. EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD WITH A LIFE SENTENCE.
AND SO HOW CAN COGNITIVE
BEHAVIOR THERAPY IN THAT MOMENT
HELP ME I DON'T I DON'T BELIEVE.
FOR ME IT WOULD WHAT HELPED ME
WAS REALLY GOING BACK
UNDERSTANDING THE EIGHT YEAR OLD
ME WHEN MY PARENTS DIVORCE AND
THE EMOTIONAL TRAUMA THAT WAS
DEVELOPED OVER TIME.
YES I COMMITTED MY CRIME AT THE
AGE OF EIGHTEEN AND I MADE A
CONSCIOUS CHOICE THAT DAY THAT
NIGHT.
HOWEVER MY ABANDONMENT FROM
EIGHT YEARS OLD MY EXPERIENCES
OF NEGLECT AND ABANDONMENT AT
TWELVE YEARS OLD.
MY HOMELESSNESS A SEVENTEEN YEAR
OLD WHICH REINFORCED NOT THIS
PHYSICAL STRUCTURE ON HAVE A
PLACE TO STAY BUT THE
REINFORCEMENT OF YOU DON'T
MATTER YOU DON'T CARE.
THE NEED.
FOR A FATHER FIGURE WHO WAS
ABSENT IN MY LIFE THE AGAIN
AMANDA MANY LIKE THOSE THINGS
AREN'T NECESSARILY ADDRESSED AND
ADDRESS AT THE ROOT OF WHERE
THEY HAVE BEEN.
AND SO WHEN I STARTED TAKING
THESE --
PROGRAMS THAT WERE ALSO
COMMUNITY BASED BRAND WHICH IS
VERY VERY IMPORTANT MY OPINION.
BECAUSE THE BIG DIFFERENCE IS
THERE'S A HUGE BUST.
THE FOR ME AND FOR MANY MEN AND
WOMEN IN SADDAM'S ONLY FOR WOMEN
OR MEN MANY OTHER FRIENDS THAT
ARE SPOKEN TO INSIDE.
LOT OF TIMES WE DID NOT FEEL
LIKE WE WERE EVER PART OF
SOCIETY OR COMMUNITY TO BEGIN
WITH -- I
STRUGGLE AT HOME WITH WITH
ISSUES I WENT TO SCHOOL ANDYES
MY BEHAVIOR SHOWED UP IN SCHOOL
BUT I WAS CONSIDERED A QUOTE
UNQUOTE BAD IT.
AND SALAS TAKEN OUT OF THE
CLASSROOM PUT IN DETENTION OR
SUSPENSION WE'RE LITERALLY MY
FUTURE DEPENDENT ON ME BEING IN
THE CLASSROOM.
AND SO WHAT I WAS OBSERVED AS IS
AN ACADEMIC FAILURE.
AND MY EMOTIONAL --
ARMS WERE NEVER DEALT WITH THAT
EIGHT NINE ON I STILL NEVER FELT
LIKE OKAY I DON'T BELONG AT HOME
I DON'T BELONG IN SCHOOL.
I WAS KICKED OUT OF HOME NOW TO
BELONG IN SOCIETY AND SO
THEREFORE AT LEAST LIKE A
LOGICALLY --
SOCIETY RULES NO LONGER APPLY TO
ME.
AND THERE ARE GOING TO COMMIT
MORE CRIMES.
AND COMING INTO PRISON THERE IS
A HUGE CULTURE OF IS ABUSIVE
CULTURE OF POWER AND CONTROL IS
ACTUALLY.
HOT FOR THE CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS IT'S TIED TO PAID STAFF
THAT OVERSEE THE PRISON PROGRAMS.
LIKE IF YOU GUYS SIT IN THE
TRAINING HONOR SENATE TRAINING
BUT JUST.
KNOWING HEARING ABOUT IT SITTING
IN THE TRAINING IT'S THE
MANIPULATORS THEY'RE GONNA TRY
TO DO THIS YOU DON'T GIVEN THIS
DON'T GIVEN THAT TREAT HIM LIKE
THAT THAT THERE.
THEY'RE TAUGHT WITH ABUSE AND
CONTROL IS IS THE IS THE WAY TO
FUNCTION AND DEAL WITH HUMAN
BEINGS -- EN
EN.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS I
WANT TO SAY DO NOT DO THAT.
IT IN THE AUDIT IT WAS CLEAR TO
ME RIGHT WHEN I READ IT IS SAID
THAT SANK NGUYEN HAD THE LOWEST.
CAMINO A CVT ENROLLMENT RATE
COGNITIVE BEHAVIOR THERAPY
ENROLLMENT RIGHT.
THAT'S BECAUSE IN IN SEGUIN THE
LAST FOUR YEARS I SPENT THERE.
THIS IS SO HUGE ON COMMUNITY.
MAYBE IS THE GEOGRAPHIC LOCATION
IS STRUCTURED AND IN THE MIDDLE
MARIN QUOTE UNQUOTE LIBERAL BAY
AREA I DON'T KNOW BUT IT HAS
ACCESS TO PEOPLE --
AND SO WHEN PEOPLE ARE COMING IN
THERE THEY WERE BRINGING THEIR
PROGRAMS WITH THEM.
SO LOT A LOT OF THE MEN INSIDE
WERE LIKE I'M NOT GOING TO SEE
THE PROGRAM WHERE.
IT'S A PAID CDC OUR STAFF.
AND THERE'S NO TRUST THERE I'M
GOING TO WEAR WE'RE JUST
COMMUNITY WHERE I FEEL LIKE I'M
LAW -- IN
THEIR MIND IN THEIR HEART AND
SOUL IF I'M SUPPOSED TO EXPECTED.
TO SIT IN A PROGRAM.
WELL SUPPOSED TO SHARE MY
INNERMOST JAMES TRAUMAS HAYNES.
A HERTZ WHATEVER THAT MAY BE.
BUT I DON'T TRUST THE PERSON I'M
SAYING THAT TO THE WORK IS NOT
GOING TO BE DONE.
INTERNALLY IS NOT GOING TO BE
DONE.
BUT IF I'M SITTING IN A IN A
CULTURE IN A IN A IN A CLASSROOM.
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE PERSON I'M
AND THE PEOPLE I'M SPEAKING.
TO I TRUST THEM THEY HERE FOR MY
INTEREST THE NOT SEAT CDC ARE OR
OR ENOUGH FROM PORTABLE THE MAN.
THAT I I BELIEVE I CAN REALLY
SPEAK ABOUT MY MY TRAUMAS AND
FIND HEALING.
ALSO A LOT OF THE CBC PROGRAMS
DID NOT ADDRESS VICTIM IMPACT.
TO A DEGREE THAT I FEEL LIKE
IT'S IMPORTANT OUR ORGANIZATION
RESTORED IT JUST RESTORE JUSTICE.
UNDER OU STAFF WE HAVE
SURVIVORS OF CRIME PEOPLE WHO
HAVE LOST LOVED ONES TO VIOLENCE.
WORKING ALONGSIDE WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE COMMITTED HARM.
UNDERSTANDING WHAT HEALING MEANS
WERE BOTH SIDES INDIVIDUALLY AND
COLLECTIVELY AND THAT THAT WAS
LACKING IN MY OPINION IN THE CBC
PROGRAMS.
ON SO SO THAT IS ANOTHER THING I
THINK CULTURE HAS A LOT TO DO
WITH IT --
IS IS I CAN GO INSIDE A
CLASSROOM SURE I CAN BE IN A
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION.
GROUP WAS SOON AS I STEP OUT I'M
BEING TOLD TO GET OVER HERE GO
THERE SHUT UP SIT DOWN.
ABUSIVE LANGUAGE CONTROLLING
LANGUAGE AND IT'S KIND OF
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE --
AN EXAMPLE LIKE TO USE I DON'T
WANT TO OFFEND ANYONE ELSE IN
THE MILITARY BUT SOMEBODY IS
SUFFERING FROM PTSD WOULD YOU
PUT HIM IN A PUNITIVE CULTURE.
TO HELP HELP THEM OVERCOME PTSD.
MANY MEN AND WOMEN IN PRISON
SUFFER FROM PTSD.
WAR ZONES MAYBE WITHIN THE HOME
COMMUNITY --
ENVIRONMENTS.
SUFFER FROM PTSD AND I NEED TO
BE SEEN AS SUCH [inaudible]
AND I SEE LOOK AT THE CLOSER NOW
WILL OF WIND DOWN BUT I DO WANT
TO SAY THAT.
THERE'S ALSO A DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN VOLUNTEERISM AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
VOLUNTEERISM IS ONE THING WHERE
PEOPLE CAN COME AND GIVE THEIR
TIME.
AND GO BACK INTO THE NINE TO
FIVE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THEY'RE NOT A FIVE THAT IS THEIR
JOB.
THEY EMOTIONALLY.
INVESTED THEY ARE THEY ARE THEIR
CAREER IS INVESTED IN THIS TYPE
OF WORK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
QUESTIONS FOR MY CALL.
OKAY --
CENTER VOEPEL HEAD.
I'VE BEEN TO A LOT OF PRISONS
OKAY.
IT SEEMS LIKE THEY'RE ALL
DIFFERENT THERE ARE DIFFERENT
COUNTRIES.
LOOK AT THE WAY THEY OPERATE THE
MANAGEMENT --
THE PHILOSOPHY --
DO YOU HAVE ANY COMMENTS ON THAT
OF SAN QUENTIN IS DIFFERENT LIKE
YOU POINTED OUT I DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY.
SOLUTION.
OF YOU PROBABLY BEEN A FEW.
DIFFERENT ONES --
WE HAVE WE HAVE A STATEWIDE
SYSTEM AND WE TRY.
TO DO THESE STATEWIDE PROGRAMS.
THEN WHEN THEY GET NEEDS AND OF
THE THIRTY WHATEVER THIRTY FIRE
THIRTY FIVE PRISONS.
OF THEIR DONE DIFFERENTLY.
DEPENDING ON WHO'S IN CHARGE.
RIGHT SO DO YOU HAVE A IN
GERMANY --
COMMENTS ABOUT HOW YOU WOULD
CHANGE THAT OF LIKE WHAT KINDS
OF THINGS WE NEED TO DO THE
OPERATE IN A DIFFERENT MODEL --
HOW HOW HOW CAN BE DONE IN A
MORE EFFECTIVE WAY?
BECAUSE OF YOU KNOW WHEN I READ
THE AUDIT I READ THE OTHER.
TWO OF COURSE I WASN'T VERY
HAPPY TO READ THAT WE HAD.
YOU KNOW LIMITED IMPACT.
BUT I DON'T KNOW I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE ONLY WAY A MEASURE
THOSE PROGRAMS.
WHAT TIME SIX KIND OF?
YOU KNOW WHEN I WHEN I MEASURE
PROGRAM I WANT TO SEE IT.
BUNCH OF DIFFERENT.
FACTORS OF MORE SOPHISTICATED
WAY OF MEASURING A PROGRAM.
AND AND I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
THE RIGHTWAY TO DO IT YOU KNOW
SO YOU CAN SEE.
YOU KNOW.
IF IT MAY NOT HAVE AN IMPACT ON
RECIDIVISM.
BUT HOW DID IT HAVE AN IMPACT
INSIDE THE FACILITY I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT.
WAYS TO MEASURE.
A PROGRAM SO YOU COMMENT ABOUT
THE DIFFERENT YOU KNOW THE
NATURE OF OUR THIRTY FOUR
CALIFORNIA PENAL INSTITUTIONS WE
HAVE AN YOUR FEELINGS ABOUT HOW
WE SHOULD CHANGE THOSE.
THE THE SERVICES AND PROGRAMS I
HAVE I HAVE SOME UPS VOTE FOR
YOU.
NUMBER REALLY IT WOULD HAVE TO
SAY TO OF IN CONGRATULATIONS ON
YOUR OWN OBAMA FELLOWSHIP OF
THANK YOU YEAH YOU'RE A MOM OF
FELLOW HERE.
MANY OF OUR OTHER IS LIKE TWENTY
OR TWENTY OF US TWENTY IN THE
COUNTRY AND HIS ONE OF HIS OWN
COUNTRY. ONE OF OUR BOMBING
FELLOWS --
WELL IT AND TO ME JUST BECAUSE
YOU BECAUSE YOU BROUGHT THAT UP
THE THING THAT I'M.
I GUESS PROCESS OF ABOUT THAT IS
THAT.
IT VALIDATES THAT THE THE PEOPLE
WE WORK WITH MATTER.
RIGHT RIGHT WE WE WORK WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE CONVICTED OF
SERIOUS VIOLENT CRIMES --
AND WEIRS HELPING PEOPLE SEAT
LOOKED THE NARRATIVE WE HAVE
ABOUT THIS GROUP IS ALL TWISTED.
YOU THESE OF BOOKS WE HAVE WHO
TRIPPED TRUMP HAVE TREMENDOUS
CAPACITY. TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE
IN THEMSELVES AND THEN THE
TRANSFORMER COMMUNITIES --
AND THEY SAY WELL THAT'S
SOMETHING WE WANT TO LIFT UP AND
ANDAND SEE WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE
ON A LARGER SCALE --
SO THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THAT
FELLOWSHIP IS ABOUT.
UP BUT AS TO THE INSTITUTE NEXT.
YEAH WHICH ONE DONOVAN OKAY BEEN
THERE MANY TIMES.
WHAT I FIND IS THAT --
IF V. PRISON ADMINISTRATION.
ARTS PROGRAMS MEANINGFUL
PROGRAMS AND IS OPEN TO PEOPLE
FROM THE OUTSIDE COMING TO DO
THE WORK THAT THEY DO BEST --
THEN THERE'S A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
BUT IT'S NOT JUST THE HEADS OF
THIS IT.
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH EVERY LEVEL
WITHIN THE INSTITUTION I WAS AT
A PLACE.
OF OUR LEVEL FOR PRISON OF
RECENTLY.
AND THIS THIS HAPPENED BE ONE
THAT HAS HAD A REALLY TERRIBLE
RECORD OF OF VIOLENCE USE OF
FORCE -- ALL
KIND OF NEGATIVE THINGS IN IN
THE INSTITUTION [inaudible]
N..
I WAS IN THERE WITH A GROUP OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO HELP PEOPLE --
SORT OF FOCUS ON THE PATHWAY
HOME.
N..
WE'RE COMING TO THE PRISON A
STAFF MEMBER.
SAID YEAH I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD BE REWARDING THESE PEOPLE
WITH PROGRAM.
I GETS ITS ARE THERE ARE MANY
TIME RIGHT IT'S IT'S IT'S A
MENTALITY THAT'S THAT'S CLEAR
THAT.
LIKE THIS IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
BENEFITS ANYBODY WOULD JUST HELP
WITH THESE PEOPLE OUT IT'S NOT
BETTER FOR PUBLIC SAFETY IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT ESSENTIAL TO WHAT
WE'RE SUPPOSED TO BE DOING PART
OF CORRECTIONS.
UP WHERE YOU HAVE STAFF AND
WARDEN RESTED MINISTRATION I'M
COMMITTED TO MAKING THAT MAKE IT
A PLACE WHERE THIS IS THE WORK
TO BE DONE NEVER HEARD A WORD
AND SAY THAT.
NO NEVER --
WORDS SEEM TO BE MORE COMMITTED
TO THE SERVICES WELL WARDENS ARE
THAT'S DEFINITELY ONE SAID THAT
THAT THEY OWN I MEAN THANK
NGUYEN WAS ALWAYS THE SINK WHEN
WE KNOW ABOUT.
SURE -- AND
IT TOOK WARDEN BEING COMMITTED I
EN AND SUCCESS OF WORDS BEING
WILLING TO CONTINUE THAT.
BECAUSE YOU DON'T WANT OPENNESS
TO THE COMMUNITY.
A CULTURE WITHIN THE PRISON
PEOPLE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRANSFERRED IN FROM OTHER
PRISONS.
DONE TIME IN OTHER PRISONS THEY
GET THE SAME POINT IN THINKING
OKAY LET ME.
RUN IT DOWN FOR ME WHO IS
RUNNING WELL WHAT WE DO HOW TO
WHAT WHERE DO I GET A KNIFE OUT
OF IT AND PEOPLE WHO ARE ALREADY
THIS A NO THAT'S NOT WHAT WE DO
HERE.
AND IT BLOWS THE MIND.
IS AN ADJUSTMENT TO THIS
DIFFERENT CULTURE THAT IT THIS.
AND I DON'T SAVED SYNC WITH THAT
THAT ANY PRISON THIS REALLY
[inaudible]
GREAT.
BUT SAN QUENTIN HAS CREATED AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THERE'S
THERE'S SOME AGREEMENT ON ALL
SIDES THIS IS THE WORK WE'RE
HERE TO DO.
AND THAT TAKES A COMMITMENT FROM
THE WAR LEVEL ALL THE WAY DOWN
N..
BOTH SUPPORTING AND AND
REWARDING STAFF TO SUPPORT THAT.
AND DISCIPLINE THOSE WHO DON'T.
PEOPLE GET IN THE WAY OF
PROGRESS PEOPLE WHO WORK WILL
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
ACCESS PROGRAMS PEOPLE WHO ARE
COMING UP WITH REASONS TO LOCK
PEOPLE DOWN AND IN INTERFERE
WITH THE PROGRAM --
IT TAKES ADMINISTRATION BEING
COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE LOOK
LET'S REMOVE BARRIERS. TO THE
PROGRAM PARTICIPATION IS
ACTUALLY SUPPORT --
WHERE I SEE THAT HAPPENING?
PROGRAMS FLOORS.
THE N. EMITTED HELPS THE WITH
THEIR CLOSE ENOUGH TO A MAJOR
METROPOLITAN AREA THIS CAN BE
VERY DIFFICULT OR THEY HAVE TO
GET.
EXTRA CREATIVE --
TO FACILITATE THAT BUT THAT'S
THAT'S WHAT I SEE.
THANK YOU --
YES I AGREE WITH MR WILEY --
OF IF I WERE TO ADD TO THAT I
WOULD SAY THAT.
INITIALLY NOTHING IT DOES NOT
WITH THE CULTURE OF THE PRISON --
IS IT A IS IT A PLACE FOR
LEARNING IS A PLACE FOR GROWTH
IS IT A PLACE FOR ME TO SHARE
LIKE A THEN PAINS AND THAT THAT
GOES WITH THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
CALLING IN CHARGE.
OF ME ABOUT I'M GONNA SAY TWELVE
OR THIRTEEN YEARS.
BUT I'M NOT TO SINK WHEN I
STARTED MY SOME SECURITY PRISON
WORK MY WAY DOWN TO LEVEL TO SAN
QUENTIN WHY ACTUALLY SHIP AND
OFFICERS HAND --
AND I'LL ALSO SAY THEY THINK WE
CAN STILL IMPROVE WHEN IT COMES
TO THE CULTURE OF OFFICERS --
IN MY OPINION.
BUT IT TOOK ME THAT LONG TO
CHECK AN OPPOSITE HAND AND AND
THEN.
IMMEDIATELY HIT MY MY MY MY LIKE
WHOA OKAY --
NOT SO BAD.
I FEEL SAFER I FEEL SAFE.
I'M A LOT OF THE FEARS COME FROM
USE OF AUTHORITY.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
BEGINNINGS --
AND THEN NOTHING LIKE YOU JUST
MENTIONED THAT THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WILL BE
ATTRACTED BECAUSE THEY'LL BE
MORE INCLUDES INCLUDED.
INTO THESE PRISONS --
Là TIME THERE'S THIS DIVISION
OF IN MEAT LOVERS ALL THE TERM
GOING AROUND.
YOU KNOW --
KNOWN.
AND IN LANGUAGE AS THE OWNER ON
THE I'M NOT I WON'T USE HERE BUT
YOU'RE IN MAY LOWER YOUR SUCH
AND SUCH AND SO IT IT'S IT'S
MORE THESE DEMORALIZING --
AND THEN THE THE THE TROUBLE IT
TAKES FROM VOLUNTEERS OR COMMUNE
BASED ORGANIZATION TO GET IN A
PRISON.
IS CONSTANTLY OUR TURN AROUND
YOU KNOW WE'RE IN THIS EVEN
THOUGH THAT PERSON PUT IT A
WARRANT THE SAME THING THE WEEK
BEFORE I'M IT IS IS IT SEEMS
LIKE THEIR GAMES --
AN IS REALLY DEMORALIZING THEY
CAN BE AND SO THAT CULTURE I
BELIEVE NEEDS TO CHANGE --
WORK MANY VETS ORGANIZATIONS CAN
COME IN INTO THE PRISON AND WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE PEOPLE
INSIDE -- I
THINK.
IT IS ALSO CLEAR IN THE IN THE
AUDIT WHERE TO TALK ABOUT SAID
AS THE SUBSTANCE ABUSE.
ANY FACILITY CORCORAN THEY TALK
ABOUT THE RECIDIVISM RATES FOR
THE INCARCERATED MEN AND BY THAT
PROGRAM THAT THEY EVALUATED WAS
LOWER AND I'M GONNA ASK A
QUESTION NEXT ABOUT SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
AND SO SO IN THAT FACILITY.
THERE'S AN OFFICER THAT WAS
QUOTED BY SAYING THAT I AN
OPPOSITE SAID THE I BELIEVE THE
REASON WHY THAT IS BECAUSE OF
THE ENVIRONMENT.
THAT IS OFFICER SAYING THAT IN
THE AUDIT AND SO.
I THINK THAT --
NOTHING I WAS ONE ADD BRIEFLY IS
WITH ME BASS ORGANIZATIONS IF
YOU TALK ABOUT MAKING.
A CHANGE THE CULTURE --
AND LINKING IT TO RE ENTRY.
THE REASON I AM I FEEL LIKE I'M
SUCCESSFUL AND I'M SET UP TO BE
SUCCESSFUL ON MURRAY ENTRY IS
BECAUSE THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS HELPED ME.
THROUGH AND THROUGH THE DAY
AFTER THE THEIR DAY OF ON ME
THAT I GOT OUT.
THAT LINKAGE OF RE ENTRY IS NOT
THERE WHEN IT COMES TO NOT IN MY
OPINION NOT COMING BACK.
AND SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
PROPOSE OR JUST.
PUT OUT THERE THE PEOPLE ARE
LISTENING.
IS THAT MANY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NEED TO BE AT THE CENTER OF
WHATEVER THIS CULTURE SHIFT IS
GOING.
TO AND HAVE A STATE IN A HUGE
STAKE IN.
HOW WE MOVE FORWARD WITH WITH
THIS PROGRAM IS AN HOUR GOING TO
CHANGE THE CULTURE OF?
C. C. R..
AND RECIDIVISM LOWER RECIDIVISM
RATES.
I HAD A WE WE DISCUSSED IN THE
LAST FEW WEEKS HERE IN THIS
COMMITTEE --
ESTABLISHING A A MEDICAL PROGRAM
FOR SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND
INCREASING OUR PROGRAMS --
MEDICAL ASSISTED TREATMENT --
FOR INMATES AND WETALKED ABOUT --
HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE?
SUBSTANCE ABUSERS INSIDE THE
PRISON.
AND HOW HAT OVERWHELMS.
SERVE THE CULTURE IN THE PRISON --
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT --
AND YOU TALK ABOUT.
HOW WE CAN A COUNTER THE
SUBSTANCE ABUSE CULTURE?
INSIDE THE PRISONS.
HOW WELL YOU YOU THINK THIS
MEDICALLY ASSISTED TREATMENT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT SPENDING?
UPPER IS A TWO HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS. FOR THE MEDICAL STUFF
THAT WE NEED TO PUT INTO THOSE
WHAT I'D LOSE WHAT'S YOUR
OPINION I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE --
EXPLORING.
ALL THE DIFFERENT.
NOW THESE AND AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT --
UP TO NOW IT HAS BEEN --
ALCOHOLICS ANONYMOUS NARCOTICS
ANONYMOUS YEAH WELL STEP YEAH.
WHICH DOESN'T WORK FOR A LOT OF
PEOPLE --
BUT IT IS SORT OF THE FAVORED.
APPROACH ON AND WHAT I FOUND
AGAIN.
LOOKING AT AT IT THROUGH THE
PAROLE BOARD LENS.
IT IS BECAUSE IT'S A FAMILIAR
ENOUGH MODEL TO ROLL COMMISSION.
IF THEY CAN THEY CAN TRACK --
TRACK IT AS A STRUCTURED
APPROACH TO RECOVERY AND
SOBRIETY --
TWELVE STEPS OKAY WOULD YOU WORK
TWELVE STEPS AND YOU CAN SHOW
THAT YOU HAVE A CLEAN UP RECORD
BEEN LONG ENOUGH IN PRISON.
THEN YOU'VE YOU'VE ADDRESSED
THAT ISSUE.
BUT IT DOES THAT DOESN'T WORK
THE WAY FOR EVERYBODY.
AND SO THERE'S SOME OTHER
STRUCTURED WAY SOMEONE'S GOTTEN
CLEARLY MAINTAIN SOBRIETY.
RATE MOST --
AND THEN.
THEY SAY THE THREE THINGS WOULD
BE THE MEDICALLY ASSISTED
TREATMENT.
OUR NUMBER HERE ABLE SERBIAN
TWELVE STEP SO.
THE YEAH I KNOW IT IN WE'RE
LOOKING AT THIS AUDIT IS IS.
COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL THERAPY.
YOU KNOW MAYBE.
THAT'S NOT THE RIGHT DIRECTION
BUT I I'M NOT SURE I'M NOT SURE
IT'S DONE RIGHT THE THAT'S WHAT
I WOULD.
I WOULD SAY I WOULD SAY THOSE
THINGS ARE [inaudible]
I KNOW [inaudible]
PERSONALLY THAT --
MY SISTER BECAME A DRUG ADDICT
BECAUSE SHE THOUGHT.
TRAUMA SHE EXPERIENCED AS A KID
WAS OR FALL.
NOW IF NONE OF THESE GROUPS
ADDRESS THAT.
THEN THEY HAVEN'T DONE IT.
AND SO THAT THAT CORD TRAUMA.
IF IT REMAINS UNADDRESSED THEN
SORT OF FIXING IT IN THE
IMMEDIATE.
TIME DOESN'T REALLY GET THERE IT
DOESN'T HAVE A LASTING.
IN FACT I THINK BUT GEN.
IF YOU'RE IN A COMMUNITY WHERE
WE ALL AGREE THIS IS WHAT WE'RE
ABOUT.
THEN AS SOON AS I OFFER AT NINE
SOMETHING THAT HE SHOULDN'T HAVE.
THEN I'M GOING TO BE OSTRACIZED
THIS COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE THEY'VE ALL AGREE IS NOT
WHAT WE'RE DOING --
BUT YOU GOTTA HAVE YOU GOTTA
HAVE AND AND YOU KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THE OF THAT ASPECT OF
THE THE THE AUTO AUDITOR'S
REPORT.
TALK ABOUT SAID AT THE THE KEY
THAT IT WAS IT WAS A WE HAVE A A
CULTURE WITHIN THE INSTITUTION
BUT THEY CREATED THAT THEY'RE
SAYING.
WE'RE GOING TO GROUP TOGETHER
PEOPLE DOING THIS WORK AND THEY
SUPPORT EACH OTHER THAT'S WHAT
MAKES IT.
A THAT'S WHAT CREATES THE
COMMUNITY AND SO THEY AGREE THIS
IS NOT WHAT WE'RE DOING BUT YOU
CAN'T JUST SORT OF DO ONE THING.
YOU CAN'T YOU HAVE TO FIND A WAY
TO BRING THEM ALL TOGETHER AND
IT WORKS THE CREATE EVEN EVEN
THE INSTITUTION WHERE THE OTHER
YARD.
WE HAVE ONE WHERE THIS IS WHAT
OR IN ONE BUILDING THIS IS WHAT
WE DO HERE.
IT'S A START BUT YOU GOTTA OF
THE MORE THOSE POCKETS WE CREATE
THE BETTER SUCCESS WE SEE. FIVE
ADD TO THAT THINK THAT --
YEAH ABSOLUTELY NO SUBSTANCE
ABUSE IS A HUGE ISSUE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND AND AND THEN INSIDE
OF OUR PRISONS.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE --
AND I AGREE FOR THAT TOTAL
RECOVERY ACT AND ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT A RELAPSE IS PART OF
RECOVERY --
HAPPENS IT CAN BE A PART OF
RECOVERY AND UNFORTUNATELY IN
OUR PRESENT CULTURE NOW IF YOU
RELAPSE IN PRISON YOU WILL BE
DEALT WITH --
AND SO NOBODY ADMITS EVEN THOUGH
THE A OR AN A YOU CAN GO THERE
HI MY NAME'S ANONYMOUS ALCOHOLIC
OR ON THE YOU KNOW.
THE DRUG ADDICT.
I CAN'T ADMIT HEY MAN I I I I
SLID LAST NINE I HAD.
YOU KNOW I USED.
BECAUSE I'M AFRAID TO BE PUT
INTO SEGREGATION.
AND THEN GET ADMINISTRATIVE --
RIGHT UP THE WORKING JEOPARDIZE
MY FUTURE AND AND WHATEVER.
AND SO.
EVEN IF THE PERSON RELAPSE AND
AGAIN I UNDERSTAND RELAPSE TO BE
PART OF RECOVERY HAPPENS THAT'S
OF HATE IS NOT OKAY WITH OKAY --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY THAT STUFF IS
IS HITTING A HAS TO BE IT
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR.
OF OF PUNISHMENT.
SO WE LOOK AT THAT POLICY.
YEAH THANK YOU.
THAT ARE MORE LIKE.
THANK YOU MEDICARE THANKS FOR
THIS PANEL TOGETHER THIS IT'S
BEEN.
REAL HELPFUL BY BACKGROUND I WAS
A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
ORANGE COUNTY SO WE HAD. ONE
WELL ONE OF THE TOP.
TEN JAIL SYSTEMS AND IN THE IT'S
PRETTY PRETTY SIGNIFICANT SIZE
BROKE.
WHEN I WALKED INTO THE JOB --
THERE WERE THIRTY LAWSUIT IT'S
MY INMATE.
IT WOULD JUST HAVE A LOT OF
ACTIVITY THAT ALL SAID YOU KNOW
IN A CLOSED SESSION YOU START TO
REALIZE WHAT'S GOING ON IN THE
COUNTY THAT YOU.
REALLY WEREN'T PRIVY TO BEFORE.
THERE WAS ALSO A YOUNG MAN WHO
WAS -- IT
INTO ONE OF OUR JAIL STEEL LACEY
WHO -- THE
THE THE THAT BE SURE OF SOME
FORM OF THE OTHER INMATES SAID
HE HAD.
BEEN.
PUT IN THERE BECAUSE HE HAD
MOLESTED A CHILD WHICH WAS NOT
TRUE.
AND THE DEPUTIES LOOK THE OTHER
WAY WATCH TV WHATEVER AND IS HIS
FELLOW INMATES IN THAT
PARTICULAR WORD [inaudible]
PROCEEDED [inaudible]
TO VDM.
I POURED SCALDING WATER ON THE
JUMPED FROM BUNKS ON HIM.
AND WHEN THE AUTOPSY REPORT CAME
OUT I DIDN'T KNOW WE HAD THAT
MANY RIPS THAT WERE THAT WE MUST
BE BROKEN.
SO I IT'S IT'S IT'S NICE TO
KINDA.
WITH ALL THAT BACKGROUND.
BECAUSE OF OUR OTHER CONTEXT I'M
IS DURABLE AND ANYTHING YOU
BRING BACK ALL THIS.
THIS HISTORY THAT YOU.
YOU YOU HAD TO PARTICIPATE IN IT
HAD A READ ALL THESE
[inaudible]
LAWSUIT.
GRAND JURY REPORTS AND AND AND
AND THAT --
I APPRECIATE.
TRYING TO CHANGE A CULTURE.
BECAUSE THAT WAS WHAT WE HAD TO
DO.
IN ORANGE COUNTY.
NOT EASY. TO DO --
SO I SO THANK YOU THIS IS.
MEMBER VERY HELPFUL SO I I JUST
HAD A COUPLE OF QUESTIONS.
UNLIKE SENATOR BELL.
I'VE DONE A PRETTY GOOD JOB OF
STAYING OUT OF STATE PRISONS
[inaudible]
THEY DON'T.
I'M INVITING YOU TO GO WITH YEAH
YOU HAVEN'T SOLD ALWAYS.
CENTER BELLS INVITED ME TO GO TO
DONOVAN YOU'VE BEEN A COUPLE
TIMES A FEW TIMES.
I ARE TO BE HONESTLY I'VE NEVER
I'VE NEVER TOURED AT THE STATE
PRISON.
YOU KNOW AND YOU WE GET SO BUSY.
BUT A YOU KNOW I DO BECAUSE AT
THAT NEXT FRIDAY IS A MARTIN.
GIVE ME A EXCUSE ME IT'S A
HOLIDAY SO.
RIGHT MY STAFF IS NOT ANYTHING
SO I I I IN IT SAN DIEGO SO
[inaudible]
SO.
TELL ME DO I SHOULD I VISIT
[inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WHAT?
VISIT IS THAT AS MANY AS YOU CAN --
AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE YOU
GET A MIX OF SECURITY LEVELS --
BECAUSE IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT
EXPERIENCE.
AND YOU'LL SEE YOU KNOW --
I'M I REFERRED TO TO THE
HIERARCHY OF NEED YOU'LL SEE.
THAT PEOPLE ARE FOCUSED ON
SURVIVAL.
IN CERTAIN PLACES AND OTHER
PLACES THE CONVERSATION IS VERY
DIFFERENT [inaudible]
VERY DIFFERENT.
HI BUT YOU CAN ONLY SEE THAT
WHEN YOU GET IN THERE AND
ACTUALLY ACTUALLY TALKED.
TALKED WITH MANY PEOPLE CAN I
WAS THEY DON'T JUST.
DON'T JUST DON'T JUST TAKE THE
GUIDED TOUR --
GROUPS OF THAT'S GREAT YEAH.
THAT'S GOOD WAS LISTENING MORE
THAN TALKING IS A GOOD WAY TO GO
I THINK.
I ALSO ENCOURAGE GOING AS MUCH
MAGIC AND DIFFERENT FACILITY
JUVENILE FACILITIES I MEAN GIVE.
OUR PERSPECTIVE A SEGREGATED
HOUSING UNITS.
WERE IN ADMINISTRATORS.
MISSION -- I
CAN THE FIRST THAT IS TALK TO
THE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN THERE AND
I MEAN PEOPLE I MEAN I'VE HEARD --
LIKE YOU KNOW THE TERMS LIKE
INMATES AND PRISONERS AND
OFFENDERS OF CONSTANTINE USED
AND AND I I PREFER THE TERM
INCARCERATED PERSON A PERSON WHO
IS INCARCERATED OR FATHER OR
MOTHER WAS INCARCERATED --
HUMANIZES PEOPLE.
I A IN A LONG ACROSS THE
QUALIFIER OF HEY YOU ARE YOU ARE
ON A FENDER IS WHAT YOU'VE DONE
CAUSE AND REMINDING PEOPLE.
IS WRITTEN TO OUR LEGISLATION I
MEAN IT WHEN I WENT TO TRIAL IT
WAS.
IT WAS THE PEOPLE VICE VERSUS A
NON CON.
THE ALREADY I'M AGAINST THE
pPEOPLE.
I'M I'M NOT I WANT TO BE PART OF
SOCIETY AND SO YOU HAVE THESE
CONVERSATIONS WITH PEOPLE INSIDE --
I BE I BELIEVE YOU'LL BE
BENEFICIAL SO THAT I CAN THE
FIRST THAT IS TO TALK TO PEOPLE
INSIDE I THINK THE NEXT THAT IS
ENOUGH THE WHENEVER YOU HAVE THE
TIME TO GET TO KNOW PEOPLE.
I'M I THINK THERE'S A DOES THE
NEXT.
TALKING TO PEOPLE --
AND THEN.
FORMERLY INCARCERATED HUNDRED
PEOPLE UT HEE BAY AREA UP AND
DOWN CALIFORNIA THERE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED DOING AMAZING THAT
PEOPLE RIGHT BEHIND ME.
WHEN AMAZING AMAZING WORK SO IF
YOU CAN'T GO THERE COLLISON HERE?
HAVE LUNCH IN A IN OR SOMETHING
AND AND I LOVE THE FOOD OUT HERE
I'VE BEEN OUT TWO MONTHS.
IN -- LET'S
HAVE LET'S HAVE LUNCH FIRST AND
THEN WE'LL GET TO KNOW EACH
OTHER.
BUT BUT SO YES I WANNA Là
ORDINANCE FOR ANSWERS PLEASE YES.
MY LAST QUESTION AND THEN IS FOR
YOU AND THAT IS WHY DID GOVERNOR
BROWN ACT.
GRACE.
I MEAN HE WROTE IT OUT ON PAPER
BUT PERSONALLY YOU WOULD HAVE TO
ASK HIM I UNDERSTAND THAT
GETTING A COMMUTATION OF
SENTENCE IS IS LIKE WINNING.
MAYBE EVEN MORE HAVE MORE RARE
THAN THAT BECAUSE HOW.
INFREQUENTLY THEIR HANDED OUT.
ON AND SO WHY WHY DID YOU WHY
DID YOU DO ANY ON PAPER HE WROTE --
WHO HE SAW WHY WAS TODAY IN THE
WORK THAT I'VE DONE?
I'M IN A BELIEVE HE BELIEVES
THAT HE BELIEVE I'M NO LONGER A
THREAT TO PUBLIC SAFETY --
THAT'S LIKE THE IF YOU COULD SAY
I DID ANYONE IS IN IT BUT LIKE
PROBABLY THE CORRECT
[inaudible]
WRITING.
I WITH THAT YOU ASKED EXACTLY
WHAT EACH WAS MEAN --
I'M I I WOULD LIKE TO ASK IN AS
WELL -- BUT
I I WOULD DEFINITELY SAY THAT --
I'M PRIVILEGED IN THIS AND NOW
ALSO SADISM THERE ARE MANY MORE
MANY WOMEN INSIDE RIGHT NOW.
THE DESERVE THAT AS WELL.
I READ THIS.
I READ IT BECAUSE YOU'RE A GOOD
MAN NOW.
AND WHAT WOULD MAKE YOU A GOOD
MAN.
I CANNOT SAY THAT I FEEL LIKE
I'VE ALWAYS BEEN A GOOD MAN I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN A GOOD KID --
THERE'S A PIECE OF ME THAT OUT
WHAT IS THE HUGE VOID OF VACANCY
IN MY HEART THAT WASN'T FILLED --
I MEAN IF YOU ASK ME WHO I WAS.
OUR BEFORE MEETING MY CRIME NOW
IS IT EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WITH A
SENSE OF HUMOR.
WE NEEDED I'M A FATHER FIGURE
WHO NEEDED SHELTER BUT WHO LOVE
PEOPLE WHO LITERALLY GAVE ASK
DOLLARS.
HAVE A BURGER TO EAT AND THEN
FOUND AND SEVEN CENTS BECAUSE
THE DOLLAR SEVEN NINE
EISENBERGER THAT DOLLARS.
SEVEN YOU KNOW AND FIND SEVEN
CENTS TO FULLY GO GET THAT NINE
EISENBERGER THAT THAT'S WHAT WAS --
IN THAT MOMENT.
I LET MY SELFISHNESS MAMA
HOMELESSNESS EXCUSES MUCH TRAUMA
ONE GOING GROWING UP ALL ADD UP
AND I MADE THE DECISION --
THAT NIGHT TO DO THAT
[inaudible]
AND SO.
I NEARLY THREW ACCOUNTABILITY
FEW HOURS LATER WHEN I WAS
ARRESTED --
HAD GENUINE GENUINE REMORSE I
MEAN.
CRIED RIGHT MY EYES OUT THE NEXT
MORNING COULDN'T BELIEVE WHAT
WHAT HAD TAKEN PLACE IN.
AN EMPATHY AND THAT NEVER
CHANGED I THINK THAT WE TALK OR
REHABILITATION --
IT'S IT'S IT'S NOT CHANGING
SOMEBODY BUT AS IT'S REMINDING.
PEOPLE OF THE GOODNESS AND THEN --
AND SOMETIMES YOU ASKED ME A
WHAT WHY DID YOU CHANGE I DON'T
FEEL LIKE I CHANGE AYE BEALL
ABSOLUTELY UP GROWN.
BUT I'VE BEEN REMINDED OF MY
TRUE CORE MY WHY AM.
FUNNY.
PERSON CARING --
AND AND PATHETIC.
YOU KNOW SELFLESS BUT THOSE ARE
QUALITIES THAT WERE ALREADY
ALWAYS IN ME.
THERE WERE JUST.
FOSTER TO COMMUNITY AND PEOPLE.
THANK YOU SENATOR BROWN SENATOR.
MORE LIKE FOR ASKING THE
QUESTIONS THAT.
ALLOWED THESE THINGS.
TO BE EXPRESSED.
IT'S A HARD NOW TO JUST --
QUANTITATIVE OR QUALITATIVE
QUESTIONS THAT I THINK ARE LEGIT
FOR US GIVEN THAT WE'RE HAVING
HEARING TO TRY TO COME OUT BUT I
WILL DO MY BEST RIGHT NOW --
BUT THANK YOU BOTH.
EVERYTHING YOU'VE EXPRESSED A
FOR I'M.
BOTH OF YOU HAVE EXPRESSED IN
VARIOUS WAYS BUT I WOULD LIKE IF
YOU -- COULD.
TO GIVE US A LITTLE RECAP ON
WHAT YOU FEEL.
MAKES A SUCCESSFUL
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAM AND YOU
CAN BOTH PROVIDE THAT AND I HAVE
TWO OTHER QUESTIONS.
I MEAN I AM PROUD TO REPEAT WHAT
I'VE BEEN MAKING THIS WHOLE TIME
IS.
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATION AND
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT IS NOT FALL
IS MORE THAN VOLUNTEERS AND IT'S
NOT YOU KNOW GOING LIKE IT'S A
GOING TO YOUR NINE TO FIVE AND
THEN MAYBE YOU HAVE.
ON THE WEEKENDS ARE LATER ON THE
DAY. TWO HOURS IN A CLASS MANY
DAYS ORGANIZATIONS ARE FULLY
INVESTED IN THE IN THE SERVICE
OF PEOPLE AND TRULY HONORING
COMMUNITY AND THAT.
GOES INTO RE ENTRY LIKE I SAID
THE REASON I AM IN THE
SUCCESSFUL MISSION.
BECAUSE OF COMMUNITY IN TERMS OF
RE ENTRY OF A PLACE TO STAY AND
I HAVE A JOB.
BECAUSE WE AND IT WAS IMPORTANT
PART OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROGRAMS I WAS
TAKEN WHILE I WAS INSIDE --
IN FOR IT THE CBO THE COMMITTEE
BASS OR THIS THIS UPCOMING
MOVEMENT --
AND ALSO IF I COULD ADD I THINK.
I DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH THIS WILL
COST BUT MAYBE AN INDEPENDENT
NEWER EVALUATION OR NEW AUDIT
WITH INCLUDING ALL OF THESE
FACTORS THAT WE MENTION HERE --
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE THE PREVIOUS
AUDIT WITH --
SO THEY'LL BE NOW THE ONE THING
AND THEN --
BIGGER THING IS CHANGING THE
CULTURE OF THE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS WHERE PEOPLE CAN
TRULY TRULY FEEL SAFE. TO TALK
ABOUT THE SAME PAIN AND TRAUMA.
NOT JUST IN THOSE HOUR AND A
HALF OR TWO HOURS AT THEIR IN
THAT CLASS BUT BUT WHEN THEY
EXIT THEIR CLASSROOM AND GO BACK
INTO.
PRISON THAT THEY STILL FEELS.
THAT THERE'S A COMMUNITY INSIDE
A PRISON THAT STILL CARES.
I WOULD ADD TO THAT.
THE FIRST TO TO TO ECHO THAT
LAST POINT IS.
THIS IDEA OF THERAPEUTIC
COMMUNITIES THAT THAT.
THAT ARE COMMITTED.
TO THE SAFETY TO HEALING AND TO
CONFIDENTIALITY --
TO TO CREATE THE SPACE WAS
WORKING HAPPEN.
I WOULD ALSO ADD --
THE THE CRITICAL PIECE AND AND
NON TALKED ABOUT EARLIER BUT THE
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME WAY TO
CONNECT VIOLENT CRIME
[inaudible]
OF PREFERABLY IN A RESTORATIVE
JUSTICE MODEL --
THOSE PROGRAMS HAVE A HUGE
IMPACT ON EVERYONE INVOLVED
[inaudible]
PERPETRATE CRIMES.
THE THING IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
POINT AND I WOULD ALSO ADD --
THAT.
THE ROLE OF PEER MENTORS --
TO CONTINUE IN GUY THESE
CONVERSATIONS OUTSIDE OF THE
TIME THAT THEY'RE ACTUALLY LAST.
ON THE YARD --
YOU MOVING THROUGHOUT THE PRISON --
INFORMALLY AT NIGHT IN THE
MORNING THOSE CONVERSATIONS --
MAKE THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE ARE
HAVE A LASTING IMPRESSION THAT
EVERYONE GETS.
DEPRESSED DIVE POSSIBLE OUTSIDE
OF THE STRUCTURES OF THE CIVIC
PROGRAM WHICH MAY BE LETTER OR
FACILITY ABOUT CIVIL FROM THE
OUTSIDE.
THE LAST PIECE I WOULD I WOULD
ADD IS.
IT'S CONNECTED TO THE PYRAMID.
FOR YOU GOT EXPAND THE THE ROLE
IN ACCESS OF FORMERLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE --
IN THE LIVES OF PEOPLE CURRENTLY
IN.
M. ON THE OUTSIDE.
BECAUSE THEY'VE COME OUT WITH
SUCH A HUGE YOU KNOW WEALTH OF
INFORMATION SKILLS AND INSIGHTS.
AND THERE AND NOW THEY'RE BUT
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO MAKING A
DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES OF WHO
USED TO BE THAT.
RIGHT SO THAT THERE'S THOSE ARE
SOME COMPONENTS I THINK ARE ARE
REALLY CRITICAL TO SUCCESSFUL.
PROGRAMS INSIDE AND A BRIEF WE
ADD -- ONE
WHEN WHEN I WHEN I SICKENING AND
I'M GLAD YOU BROUGHT THAT ONE AS
A COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AS ONE IDENTIFY WITH THAT WHO
THE PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY ARE
THEY ARE FORMALLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE.
FLOODING THESE COMMITTEES
SURVIVORS OF CRIME BUT IN THESE
COMMUNITIES POPLE WHO HAVE
RESOURCES AND AND DIFFERENT
PRIVILEGES LET IN THESE
COMMUNITIES --
SO JUST IDENTIFY WHAT THAT
COMMITTEE.
MY SECOND QUESTION IS.
IN.
BOTH ADDRESS THIS TO A DEGREE
BUT IF YOU WANTED TO REACH OUT.
WHAT ARE THE KEY SUPPORTS AND
PROGRAMS THAT WORK UP ON REENTRY?
WE OBVIOUSLY.
PART OF WHY WE'RE TRYING TO
IMPROVE AND ENHANCE INVEST IN
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS INSIDE.
IS FOR SUCCESSFUL REENTRY BUT
THEN WE'VE ALSO.
IT'S ALREADY BEEN RAISED.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH ALONE DO THE
PROGRAM'S INSIDE.
WHAT AND WE ALSO HAVE TO DO?
UPON RELEASE AND IF YOU COULD
JUST RECAP THAT ARM.
I WOULD SAY THAT THERE HAS TO BE
CLARITY AND CERTAINTY --
AND AND IN TERMS OF THE
PLACEMENTS IN A SAFE SUPPORTIVE
[inaudible]
ENVIRONMENT.
ON THE OUTSIDE.
THAT IS NOT OVERLY RESTRICTIVE
THAT IS NOT AN EXTENSION OF THE
PRISON.
OF SOME OF THE PROGRAMS THAT
EXIST NON FOR FOCUSING ON
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING.
AND THEIR NUMBER THOSE PROGRAMS
THAT OF THAT --
COME INTO BEING IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS MOST PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
OUT OF PRISON FROM.
A AN INDETERMINATE LIFE SENTENCE
MOST OF THEM ARE GOING TO
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING FOR SIX
MONTHS OR A TWO YEAR.
SOME OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE VERY
RESTRICTIVE --
MAKE IT HARD FOR YOU TO ACTUALLY
READ A GREAT.
THEY THEY IMPOSE SOME BARRIERS
ON YOU DISSIPATE IN IN --
COLLEGE COURSES ORDER JOBS EVEN
OR OTHER PROGRAMS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE A JOB WAITING FOR YOU.
THAT THEY WILL LET YOU GET --
TO I THINK WE HAVE TO HAVE THESE
PLACES BE SUPPORTIVE AND PROVIDE.
ACCESS TO PEOPLE TO REALLY RE
INTEGRATE WITH.
AND I ALSO THINK.
THAT THEY HAVE TO BE MEANINGFUL
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EMPLOYMENT TO
USE THESE THE SOFT SKILLS
THEY'VE LEARNED WHAT.
PRESIDENT OF THE THURGOOD HARD
SKILLS TO THEY NEED ACCESS TO
TRADE UNIONS --
IN A PRESS A PROGRAMS FOR SURE
BUT ALSO A BECAUSE THEY CAN PLAY
SUCH A KEY ROLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
WE NEED TO ELIMINATE BARRIERS TO
THEM DOING THAT --
SO I WOULD I WOULD ENCOURAGE
THAT I WOULD ALSO SAY.
THAT THERE HAS TO BE SOME --
SOME TYPE OF MENTAL HEALTH
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE PEOPLE PEOPLE STRUGGLE
PEOPLE STILL DEALING WITH THEIR
CHILDHOOD TRAUMA.
AND THEY'RE DEALING WITH THE
PRISON DRAMA.
FROM FROM THE PRISON EXPERIENCE
ITSELF -- I
HAVE I'VE.
WORKED WITH A LOT OF PEOPLE WHEN
THEY COME OUT THERE LIKE YEAH
THIS IS THIS IS ART IS A LOT
HARDER IF I WOULD BE.
THE CHALLENGES I DIDN'T COULDN'T
FULLY ANTICIPATE INSIDE.
AND ARNOLD THERE AREN'T ENOUGH --
SUPPORTS FOR THEM ESPECIALLY.
IF THEY'RE NOT ON THE MENTAL
HEALTH CASE LOAD FORMALLY.
THEIR CONTACT WITH --
THE PRO OUTPATIENT CLINIC ON THE
OUTSIDE IS LIMITED --
IFNOT A MEDICATION VERY LIMITED
BUT THEY NEED THAT THAT THAT TO
REALLY SUPPORT THE TRANSITION I
THINK AND THAT THAT GOES.
TO DEALING WITH MARRIAGE AND
FAMILY IS ALSO.
AMANDA ECHOING WHEN HE SAID
NOTHING UP TO A FRIEND OF BY
SAYING THAT.
THE THE PROGRAM'S INSIDE ME TO
HAVE A DIRECT.
AND AND LIKE SUBSTANTIAL LINKAGE.
I THINK THIS IS WHAT WE OF RT.
THE MY FINAL QUESTION IS.
MR WIDELY YOU --
DESCRIBED WHAT AND COMMON LAW IS
DOING.
YOU ALSO DESCRIBED THAT YOU'RE
KIND OF SMALL --
SO I AM SENSING THAT YOU FEEL
ARE THE GREATER NEED
[inaudible]
I CAN YOU DESCRIBE OR ARE YOU
ALREADY IN THE MIDST OF OF
LOOKING OUT --
STUDYING OR DEVELOPING A
PROPOSAL FOR HOW.
YOU'RE THE TYPE OF SUPPORT YOU
PROVIDE MIGHT BE EXPANDED.
WHAT YEAH IN FACT YOU KNOW?
THINKING ABOUT ALL THE PIECES WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY.
THE THERAPEUTIC ENVIRONMENT THE
YOUR MENTOR MODEL --
PARTNERING WITH THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
ALREADY DOING A LOT OF THIS WITH
A DEEP DIVE --
THERAPEUTIC WORK INSIDE.
WHAT WE WHAT WE WOULD PROPOSE IS?
TO CREATE MORE OF THESE POCKETS
MORE OF THESE.
PLEASE FIND A A POPULATION THAT
IS MANAGEABLE MIA A DIVIDE A
COUPLE OF PRISONS.
BUT ONE IN PARTICULAR --
SO WE'LL LOOK THERE'S THERE'S
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED OR SO --
PEOPLE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES AT
THIS PARTICULAR PRISON WHAT IF
WE HAD ALL OF THEM IN THE
PROGRAM.
WHAT IF MY THE WHAT THE MODEL
WE'VE CREATED?
WAS MADE AVAILABLE TO ALL OF
THEM.
AND THAT INVOLVES FORMING CARS
REALLY PEOPLE INVOLVES TRAINING
PEOPLE WHO ARE CURRENTLY THERE.
TO HELP LEAD AND MENTOR OTHERS --
HAVING COUNSELORS AND THERAPISTS --
FROM THE OUTSIDE COME IN AND DO
THIS WORK SO THAT WHEN WE'RE
GONNA CONVERSATION EXISTS AND
THEY CREATE.
MORE THESE THESE THESE POCKETS
THESE OF THESE PLACES WHERE THEY
CAN REPLACE THE THE THE CYCLES
OF VIOLENCE THAT WE STAND WITH I
WOULD.
CALL IT CYCLES OF VIRTUE.
PLACES WHERE THEY ACTUALLY
SUPPORTIVE.
OF EACH OTHER IN ADDITION --
TO IN ADDITION TO MORE OF THEM
BEING SUCCESSFUL AS THEY GO TO
THE PAROLE CONSIDERATION PROCESS.
WE ALSO THINK WHILE THEIR THEIR
WILLS THERE IS SOME OTHER WAYS
WE CAN MEASURE WHAT SUCCESS
WOULD LOOK LIKE.
I THINK WE SEE LESS VIOLENCE IN
PRISON WE SEE FEWER USES OF
FORCE WE SEE FEWER
ADMINISTRATIVE APPEALS.
WE FEW WE SEE --
LET'S DISCIPLINE OF OF THE STAFF
MEMBERS --
AND WE SEE OVERALL GREATER
PARTICIPATION IN OTHER TYPES OF
POSITIVE PROGRAMS.
AND THOSE ALL MEASURABLE MEAN
EVERY EVERY ALL MOVEMENT IS
TRACKED ELECTRONICALLY IN
PRISONS NOW SO WE CAN KEEP AN
EYE ON HOW ALL THAT LOOKS --
BUT WE THINK THAT HAVING OF A
CONCENTRATED EFFORT. FOR SHORT
PERIOD TIME WHAT WE'RE PROPOSING
OF THIS AGO THREE YEAR PILOT
PROGRAM --
WHAT DOES THIS LOOK LIKE?
AND BY THE END OF THAT THREE
YEARS WITH THE LAST HALF
INVOLVES A A COMPREHENSIVE
ASSESSMENT.
IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES AND
DESIGN WHAT WOULD THIS LOOK LIKE
ON A STATE BY STATE.
ALL WE CAN IN OTHER WE CAN
INTENTIONALLY CREATE ON A
STATEWIDE LEVEL WHAT HAS WHAT
TOOK. TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO
CREATE IT. FOR EXAMPLE.
WE CAN CREATE MORE POCKETS LIKE
THAT SO THAT'S WHAT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE I'M HAPPY TO SHARE ALL THE
DETAILS BUT BUT YOU IT --
YOUR PARTY DEVELOP THAT PROPOSAL
YES THAT IS SOMETHING THAT COULD
BE.
YES YES I'D BE HAPPY TO SHARE
THAT WITH YES.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS MY ONLY
WORRY.
THE LAST MOMENT.
OUR HEARING WITNESSES ONE MAKE
MISTER HONOR MISTER WILEY.
I WOULD JUST SAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TO
TALK ABOUT THESE DAYS. EIGHT
EIGHT TO HEAR MR CONCERTS --
PERSPECTIVE OF SOAP SO CRITICAL
IN THIS CONVERSATION.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY.
FOR OPPORTUNITY I MEAN TWO
MONTHS OUT OF PRISON WHO WHO
GETS THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M VERY
PRIVILEGED UNDERSTAND THAT.
AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY --
AND ALSO WANT TO SAY LIKE MAYBE
OR ALL UP TO DATE GOOD QUESTION
TO ASK MILEY.
THERE'S A ORGANIZATION THAT IS
ME BASED COLLABORATIVE
ORGANIZATION THIRTY FIVE
ORGANIZATION CALLED THE
TRANSFORMATIVE --
IN PRISON WORKGROUP THE P. W..
AND I'M NOT QUALIFIED TO SPEAK
ABOUT THEM --
BUT I WOULD SUGGEST FOR SOME
MEETINGS SOME CONVERSATION.
HELP WITH THAT WHO ARE PRESENT
TODAY.
BUT AGAIN THANK YOU FOR THIS
VERY RARE OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
WELCOME THANK YOU.
PUBLIC COMMENT.
YOU CAN JUST COME UP THE MIKE.
MY NAME'S A THANK YOU FOR THIS
THE OPPORTUNITY.
AND THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE [inaudible]
PART OF YOUNG GENTLEMAN.
HI MY NAME IS --
THE NEAR NINE LA HUNDREDS OF OF
RUN ORGAN ACOSTA BURKE WAS
BODIES NEEDLES.
OUR ORGANIZATION BEGAN.
IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN FIND
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF BY THE
COMMUNITIES.
AND THROUGHOUT THE YEARS.
WE HAVE WE LEARNED THAT THAT WE
WANTED TO ADDRESS VIOLENCE.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK
BEHIND THE WALLS.
AND SO WE KNEW A LOT OF LINE AS
IT WAS THAT WAS A GROWING IN OUR
STREETS --
WAS COULD DIRECTLY.
AFFECTED TO THE TO THE PRISON
SYSTEM.
WAS IN THIS PROCESS --
IT'S BEEN FORTY SOMETHING YEARS.
THIRTY OUT ALMOST THIRTY OF
THOSE YEARS HAVE BEEN VOLUNTEER
WORK INSIDE THE INSTITUTIONS.
TRYING TO BRING SOME SANITY INTO.
THE ISSUE WHAT WE CALL THE
MADNESS OF VIOLENCE.
IN OUR STREETS --
I COME FROM A FROM --
BY MORTAR FAMILY IN THE SILICON
VALLEY -- IN.
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN ONE OF MY
RELATIVES WOULD TO PERSON.
IN. NINETEEN SIXTY TO MY FATHER
IN.
THERE WAS BROTHERS [inaudible]
WHAT PART [inaudible]
GO VISIT.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE THE PHONE
MYSELF INCARCERATED.
IS GOING ON IN IN. NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE ELEVEN MEMBERS OF
MY FAMILY WENT PRISON.
CLOTHING MEN TO ANNOUNCE.
AND HASN'T STOPPED [inaudible]
IN.
IN THE EIGHTIES WE HAVE THIRTY
FIVE MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY IN
PRISON.
I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO GO TO A THE UNIVERSITY.
I'M ALSO A VIETNAM VETERAN I
CAME BACK UP I HAVE ONE AT AS I
SEE MANY VETERANS TIED
INSTITUTIONS TODAY --
IT'S BEEN A JOURNEY.
LAST YEAR A BURIED MY SEVENTIES
RELATIVE VIOLENCE.
DRUGS ALCOHOL GANGS YOU NAME IT
YOU KNOW [inaudible]
AND YOU WONDER WHAT WHAT DO YOU
DO YOU KNOW AND I FIND MYSELF.
WHEN PRISON?
IN A CELL IN FRESNO CALIFORNIA.
WHAT HAPPENS?
IT WAS MY I HAD JUST GONE EXCEPT
THE UC SANTA.
FIRST OF A FAMILY.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE.
FOR IN GET PICKED UP THAT DAY
THEY'RE ALL MY RELATIVES DID.
I WAS IN A CLASSROOM.
SOMEONE BELIEVED IN ME.
SOMEONE BELIEVE MISTER WE'RE
GONNA GET YOU OUT HERE.
YET IN THE FRESNO GO BACK TO UC
SANTA CRUZ.
YOU HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY ROUTE.
AND I DID.
I GOT OUT.
NOW WHEN AND HAVE DEDICATED MY
LIFE SENSE. ONE EGG I JUST I
JUST.
COMPLETE THIRTY TWO YEARS CLEAN
AND SOBER [inaudible]
AND WHAT I TAKE INTO THE
INSTITUTIONS AND WHAT I ORGAN
SYSTEM DOES IS.
CULTURE AND SPIRITUAL WAY.
BECAUSE AS OUR RELATIVES WERE
SAYING RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S MANY PROGRAMS BUT IF
YOUR SPIRIT IS BROKEN.
NO MATTER HOW MANY --
PROGRAM YOU PUT IN.
AND NOT ONLY ARE THE SPIRITS OF
THE RELATIVE TO THEIR CARS RATED
BUT THE SPIRITS OF THE PEOPLE
THAT WORK THERE IS ALSO BROKEN.
AND A LOT OF THOSE PEOPLE IN AND
AS A AS A VETERAN WITH PTSD AND
DRUG ADDICTION I AND AND THE I
DON'T WORK WITH MANY VETERANS.
AN INSTITUTION THAT I THAT I AM
CURRENTLY [inaudible]
WORK IN.
VOLUNTEERING IS A TWO HUNDRED
VETERANS.
MAJORITY WOULD BE ENOUGH.
SO I I I AND I PRAY I PRAY WITH
THEM I TALKED TO MY BUT I I
WANTED TO THE JUST BE FRIDGES
SHOW YOU.
ARM IN WORDS OF A WE'VE DONE
EVALUATIONS WE'VE DONE THIS
PROGRAMS.
UNDER THIRTY YEARS OF WOMEN IN.
WELL WE'VE NEVER TAKEN A SENT
[inaudible]
CITY YOUR WE IS ALWAYS BEEN --
EITHER WE ALSO HAS SOMEHOW.
OR WE ON WE JUST.
FUN REYES WHATEVER WE NEED TO DO.
BUT THE REASON THAT WE WENT IN
THERE IS DISTRUST OF THE
VIOLENCE.
AND WE KNEW IT WE COULD REACH.
THE BROTHERS INSIDE.
THERE WE COULD HAVE.
MULTICULTURAL CITIES WERE BLACK
WHITES EVERYBODY COULD SIT
TOGETHER IN THOSE A. B.
INCARCERATE THE NO THAT'S NOT.
WE KNEW THAT WE COULD DANCE IN
THE YARD AND HOLD.
N. BLACK WHITE NORTHERNERS
OTHERS FROM ALL DIRECTIONS.
IF THE SPIRIT CAME IN.
WHAT THEY WHAT THEY CALL A
MEDICINE GOOD MEDICINE?
ALL THESE WE HAVE DONE
[inaudible]
I AM.
IF I HEARD IT ON THE QUESTIONS
DID YOU SAID IN AN IN MY
EXPERIENCE --
IT'S BEEN HARD.
TO WALK [inaudible]
THEN LINE.
THERE ONE IS IS THE RELATIVES IN
THERE.
AND THE ADMINISTRATION.
WHAT TO ME THAT I'VE BEEN ABLE
TO TUNING?
WORK WITH A LOT MINISTRY --
THAT I YOU KNOW AS AS YOUNG MAN
SAID TWO FIFTY IN THIRTEEN YEARS
THE FAGAN OFFICER.
WITH TOOK A LONG TIME FOR MAY
ALSO.
THAT I COULD FEEL THAT WE'RE NOW
I IT WAS WORKING.
IT WAS THE TENNIS IN CAP DOES
THAT WE TALK ABOUT STRATEGY.
THE ISSUE STILL VIOLENCE.
IN OUR AND THE PERSON.
WE NEED TO ADDRESS BILLS.
I THINK THAT WE IT IT TO THE
CULTURAL SPIRITUAL WAYS.
THAT WE CAN ADDRESS THAT.
BECAUSE THE ONE AND SO I JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
NOSE.
BUT LOOK AT IT FROM A
PERSPECTIVE OF INDIGENOUS
PERSPECTIVE.
IS IT WHERE IN THE SITUATION
RIGHT NOW IN THE CORRECTIONS
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX.
NUMBER AT THAT THIS SECRETARY.
HAS THIS IN A LITTLE BIT IN THE
OUTSIDE THE BOX. TO ALLOW US TO
DO AND SOME KIND OF PEACE AND
HARMONY AMONG OTHER PEOPLE.
ESPECIALLY RIGHT NOW WITHIN THE
LATINO POPULATION IN THE
INSTITUTIONS.
WHICH IS VERY.
CLOSE AND VERY DEAR. FIFTEEN
RELATIVE.
TO MY GRANDSON IS IN A DESPITE
AS AN ADULT.
BUT I DON'T GIVE A AND I DON'T
GIVE UP ON HIM.
I DON'T AGREE WITH WHAT HAPPENED
BUT I DO NOT GIVE UP ON HIM AND
I TRY TO ENCOURAGE OTHER FAMILY
MEMBERS.
ANOTHER VETERANS AND OTHER
GRANDFATHERS TO CONTINUED
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FOR YOUR I NEED TO INSTALL THE
MISSION SO THAT RIGHT.
SO THAT --
WHEN I WENT THERE WITH THE ANY
TRAIL?
YES --
MEMBER THAT.
WE HAD A DENNY'S THERE WHEN WE
HAD -- ON A
THEY WOULD WITH AN INCREDIBLE
THINGS.
INSIDE THE INSTITUTIONS ISLAND
VOLUNTARY ATTENDED A MEMBER WHEN
YOU ASKED ME TO SPEAK AT THAT
GROUP.
OF THAT THOSE PROGRAMS ARE GREAT
THAT YOU'RE RUNNING I JUST WANNA
STILL ME.
TELL TELL US SO I'M A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR PROGRAM THAT YOU RUN.
IT'S A WONDERFUL PROGRAM
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HELLO -- MY
NAME IS TROY WILLIAMS.
AND I'M CURRENTLY --
IN SCHOOL AS SAN FRANCISCO STATE
UNIVERSITY STUDY IN BROADCAST
JOURNALISM.
I AM ALSO --
RUNNING MY OWN PROGRAM I WAS --
WATER THEY FELLOWSHIP --
FROM THE SOROS FOUNDATION.
AND I AM COORDINATOR OF THE
PROGRAM AT THE BILL KAULITZ
CALLED RISE WE WORK WITH FROM
THE CAR ST THE PEOPLE COMING
HOME [inaudible]
HIGHER EDUCATION.
AND FOUR YEARS AGO I WAS SERVING
A LIFE SENTENCE.
I WOULD NOT BE HOME --
FOR FOR PEOPLE LIKE KEITH WILEY
BUT FOR THESE IN THE BASE
ORGANIZATIONS.
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE ENOUGH IN ME
TO WORK THROUGH --
SOME OF MY ANGER AND SOME OF MY
ISSUES TO HELP ME DISCOVERED --
TUITION --
ESKI SORT OF MENTIONED EARLIER.
OFFER ME A SORT OF WORK IN THE
WAY THAT.
I STARTED GETTING INVOLVED IN A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS INSIDE.
AND THEN --
I MAY BE.
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVE ENOUGH FOR
ME TO COME SUPPORT ME --
AND THEN HE STARTED ASKING ME
THESE QUESTIONS THAT THE
PROGRAMS ARE.
AND A BRIDGE THE CONNECTION FROM
THE ARM ABOUT WHAT I ACTUALLY
NEED TO TAKE INTO THEIR BOARD
ROOM TO SHOW THE BOARD --
THAT -- I
WAS NOT THE SAME PERSON WHO
COMMITTED THE CRIME --
EIGHTEEN YEARS PRIOR
[inaudible]
OF ALSO ON ONE SHOW THIS.
IS THAT --
THESE ARE MY DISCHARGE PAPERS --
I'M NO LONGER ON PAROLE --
I ONCE I DO NOW FACILITIES IN
ADULT FACILITIES --
ALL OVER THE CALIFORNIA IN SOME
CASES SOMETIMES ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY --
TO TALK TO SHARE MY EXPERIENCES.
OF AND I'M I'M I'M SO THE GIVING
YOU THIS LAUNDRY LIST OF STUFF
THAT I DO BECAUSE I AM SOMEBODY
WHO HAS.
BENEFITED FROM THE COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS COMING IN.
N. N. SPENDING THE TIME WITH US
AND SHOWN AS BEING MODELS OF HOW --
TO SHARE YOUR EMOTIONS ARE HOW --
TO PROCESS YOUR EMOTIONS RIGHT I
DIDN'T LEARN FROM SOME HELLO
WATSON SOMEBODY DO IT.
RIGHT AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE WHEN YOU HAVE
REAL PEOPLE COME IN AND SHOW YOU
REALLY MOTIONS --
MADAM SPEAKER --
I DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO ADDRESS
YOU [inaudible]
BUT I REMEMBER WHEN YOU CAME
INSIDE -- IN
THE WAY THAT YOU SPOKE INSIDE --
WAS ONE OF THE MOMENTS THAT I
WON'T FORGET BECAUSE IT SHOWED
ME THAT PEOPLE CARE.
RIGHT THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE EVEN
IN SOME OF THE HIGHEST OFFICES
IN GOVERNMENT.
LIKE THAT THEY CAN.
WRITE ANY REALLY THAT WAS UP TO
ME TO HAVE AFFECT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT REALLY --
HELP ME TO START THE LOOKING
DEEP INSIDE THE FIGURE OUT WHAT
LED ME DOWN THE PATH.
THAT I WENT DOWN THE I LIKE TO
SAY OF I THAT I GO FROM BEING
THESE INNOCENT KID WHO LITERALLY
WITH NOT STEP ON IT AT TO BE A
GUN TOTING GANG BANG A FELLOW
WITHIN THE PUT A GUN TO SOMEONE.
WHAT HAPPENED IN MY LIFE AND IT
WAS THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS THAT HELP?
ME UNDERSTAND THAT AND WILL NOT
BEGIN.
I MADE A COMMITMENT TO DEDICATE
MY LIFE TO OTHERS SO THAT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE TO CUT.
DOWN THE SAME PATH --
THESE ORGANIZATIONS NEED HE
SHOULD BE.
LIKE FUNDED.
WE CAN EXPECT THEM --
TO DO THINGS WITHOUT THE FUNDING
AND THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED --
TO DO THAT SO I HIGHLY ENCOURAGE.
PLEASE VISIT THE VISIT THE
PRISON LEARN AS MUCH AS YOU CAN
A BODY AND ON THE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE ON THE GROUND.
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK BECAUSE
THEY ARE THE ONES THAT CAN'T
FORCE.
REHABILITATION CANNOT BE.
FORCED UPON.
RIGHT WE CAN SIT IN THE ROOM AND
WILL PEOPLE START.
OF FROM THE FORCED THINGS THEN I
WILL PLAY A GAME BECAUSE YOU
WANT TO GET IT I'M JUST GONNA
GET FINAL AND THEN I'M LEAVING
I'M I HAVE ALL THE CHANNELS BUT
NO REAL WORK.
YOU KNOW ACT IS DONE RIGHT BUT
IF YOU REALLY WANT LIKE REAL
WORK TO GET DONE THE NEEDS OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO IT.
ONE REASON THAT I DID NOT --
OR STOP PARTICIPATE IN PROGRAMS
THAT WAS SANCTIONED BY --
CC ARE OR LED BY THEN.
IS THERE I WAS AN ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASS.
WHEN I WAS THE SENATE NEVER?
AND I WENT THROUGH I HAD A
CONFRONTATION WITH A BAR.
AND I WANTED TO FIGHT THIS GUARD.
RIGHT AND IF YOU LOOK AT I GOT A
RAP SHEET OUT OF THIS WORLD.
I WANTED TO FIGHT THIS GUARD AND
I WENT TO MY ANGER MANAGEMENT
GROUP.
AND I TOLD THE GUY IN THERE WHAT
I WAS GOING THROUGH AND I WON
THE FIGHT TO GUARD YOU KNOW
SAYING BUT I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT A DIFFERENT WAY TO DEAL WITH
THIS BECAUSE YOU KNOW TOLD ME.
THIS WILL STOP THEM AND WE JUST
BEEN FIGHTING [inaudible]
AND WHEN I WENT TO THE WAR ROOM
THE BOARD ASKED ME ABOUT.
AND THAT WAS I LIKE I'M NEVER
GOING TO ANOTHER ST OVER AGAIN.
AND THAT RUINED MY TRUSTS SHOP
WITH ME IN THAT MOMENT AND AND I
SAY THIS BECAUSE I ALSO RESPECT
THE JOB THIS EASY ARE HAS A DO
WITH THE GARCIA SAFETY.
AND I DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE
THAT ANY KIND OF WAY BUT I THINK
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHOSE
ACTUALLY PROVIDING A PROGRAMS.
AND HOW THOSE PREVENTION ACT
REACHED ALL THE WORK THAT NEEDED
AND OUR REGION THOSE OF US THAT
NEED IT WE ARE AND WE ARE
REACHING OTHER PEOPLE ARE IN THE
COMMUNITY RIGHT NOW.
SO THERE'S A CHAIN AFFECTED AND
BENEFIT TO WHAT HAPPENS INSIDE
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YEAH THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO OWN SHARES
JUST ALITTLE BIT ABOUT MY
PERSPECTIVE AND SOME.
FROM MY OWN STORIES I'M SO MY
NAME IS BARI I AM ALSO KNOWN AS
PJ.
I CURRENTLY WORK AS A PROJECT
MANAGER FOR THE CRYPT AN
INSTITUTE I'M ALSO ONE IS A
GREAT PROGRAM.
I'M ALSO WORKED WITH HIM AS A
COLLECTIVE AS WELL AS EDUCATORS.
AND A WHAT AS AN COMMITTEE
ADVOCATES. FOR THE ASIAN PRISON
SUPPORT COMMITTEES I DO STUFF
AND WE CAN TREAT TO IMMIGRATION
TO POLICY TO EDUCATION.
AND WILL WORK I'M ALSO ON ALICIA
TEAM FOR TRANSFORM IMPRISONED
WORKGROUP.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY I
MIGHT JUST FROM ECKELS WHAT WE
SHOULD DO YOU ABOUT.
FROM COMMITTEE BASED
ORGANIZATION PROGRAMS BECAUSE I
WAS FOURTEEN YEARS OLD WHEN I
WAS ON I COMMITTED A CRIME
ABSENCE TO LICENSE.
AND I REMEMBER LIKE I LILY GREW
UP IN PRISON AND I DID.
EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM THAT OFFER
TO FROM FROM FROM GETTING MY GED
FROM GOING TO HIGH SCHOOL IN IN
IN HIS FORTIES.
FROM IN A WORKING IN THE KITCHEN.
TO TO TO GETTING MUCH WEIGHT ON
AS A WELDER'S AS FABRICATORS
BITTER AUDI BECAUSE MISTER SHIN
AND ALL OF THE STUFF.
I'VE ALSO LIKE.
WAS BENEFIT --
FORTUNATE TO TAKE ADDITION
RECOVER CONSTANT SERVICES BECAME
A COUNSELOR I WILL.
ALSO WORK WITH BEEN CLASSIFIED
AS A DOMESTIC VIOLENCE COUNSELOR
A CERTIFIED AS A RAPE CRISIS
COUNSELOR.
SO I WORKED ON A LOT OF FEELS IN
PRISON AS A GROUP IN PRISON I
WAS INVESTED IN PRISON
[inaudible]
ON AS A YOUNG PERSON GREW UP IN
PRISON I CAN TELL YOU.
LIKE IS PROBABLY VERY DIFFICULT
TO NAVIGATE PRISON WHEN YOU'RE
YOUNG AND AFFORDABLE.
YOU DON'T KNOW NOTHING ABOUT
LIFE PEOPLE JUST.
COME TO YOU IN ANY WAY THEY CAN.
I WAS FORTUNATE BECAUSE TWO
THOUSAND FOUR I WAS AT THE
COMING OUT OF ISSUE.
FROM OUT A WHOLE I'VE END UP.
GOING TO A PROGRAM CALLED THE
REBEL PROGRAM AND WAS RUN BY A
NATIVE AMERICAN RITUALS LOCAL.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE REBEL
PROGRAM I REMEMBER FOR THE FIRST
TIME WE WE SAT IN A CIRCLE WITH
A WITH A PEOPLE.
AND THE MY MY FACILITATOR WAS
SHARING HIS EXPERIENCE.
THE GUYS WHO WAS AROUND WILSHIRE
AND EXPENSE AND AND ALL THESE
PEOPLE ARE LIFERS HUSBAND
EXPENSE OF TIME I'VE NEVER SEEN
A MAN BEEN SO VULNERABLE.
ABLE TO SHARE SO OPENLY ABOUT.
BOMBER UP THERE.
DOT COM IS ABOUT THINGS I DIDN'T
GIVE BUILDING UP.
AND I REMEMBER MY FACILITATOR
SHARING OF THE LOS TWO DAUGHTERS
THE CRIME.
AND I REMEMBER. FOR THE FIRST
TIME.
IN MY LIFE.
WELL I'VE NOT EVEN THINK ABOUT
THIS GOING UP BECAUSE I'VE SOLD
CAUGHT UP WITH ONE SURVIVED MY
ENVIRONMENT.
MY MY MY PRISON.
GANGS AND THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF
IS HAPPENING MY APARTMENT I
DISCONNECTED FROM FOR MYSELF.
MY VALUES ABOUT WAS WAYS WITH.
AND WHEN I SAID IN A ROOM AND
THOSE GUYS SHARED MY
FACILITATION HOW THE LAWSUIT
CRIME I REALIZED I DID EXACT
SAME THING TO ANOTHER.
EN EL WOKE ME UP SHOOK ME TO
RECORD FROM THAT MOMENT ON I
JUST TALKED TO MY YOU KNOW WHAT
I WOULD CHANGE MY LIFE.
AND A SPARKLE BACK SCHOOL OKAY
MUCH WAITED GET INVOLVED IN
PROGRAMS.
AND I COULD TELL YOU I GET ALL
ALREADY AND I'VE I WAS A
COUNSELOR FOR THE DICTION THE T.
VERY WILL.
TELL YOU IS NOT ONE THING THAT
THE CHANGE A PERSON'S NOT ONE
THING THAT THE BALLOT PERSON BUT
IS A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT THAT THE COMPASS IT.
IN PSALM WORKING AS A
FACILITATOR FOOTBALL LOOKING FOR
A SPECIFIC GRIP.
I WAS ABLE TO HELP US TO COME TO
MY DICTION CLASS AND SAY LOOK
YOU NEED TO TAKE THIS PROGRAM.
BECAUSE THEY'RE SHARING THEIR
LIFE EXPERIENCE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THAT THE GAP
BECAUSE I HAVE GONE THROUGH WITH
ANOTHER WAS A GAP IN MY LIFE
THAT WAS AND FEEL.
AND I'M NOT THESE PROGRAM IS
GREAT AT THE WINDOWS GOT.
THE SOUL A LOT OF MY PARTICIPANT
WHO GONE THROUGH THIS PROGRAM.
WE CAN ON OUR VICE AND ACTUALLY
LIKE EXCEL AND MOST MORE HOME
NOW THEY FEEL LIKE.
DID WAS GUYS WHO COULDN'T
COMMUNICATE EVEN LIKE SPEAK
ENGLISH.
I'D ARE TAKING SPANISH CLASS
ISN'T GOING TO EDUCATION AND
THEN LIKE THEY'RE GETTING YOUR
SUPPORT.
AND THE COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAM
WAS THERE FROM THE WHOLE WAY
AROUND HE TALKED ABOUT.
THE MENTORSHIP PROGRAM I SAW
GRIP WE USED TO HAVE.
A SIGN PEOPLE TO OR ALL PROGRAM
INVOLVED WITH THE SAME WAY LIKE
THE FACILITATOR WOULD MAKE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE IN THE MORNING
Là GUYS ARE GOING TO TO CHOW
HALL.
THERE WAS SET THE STANDARD AND I
REMEMBER LIKE WHEN I DID THE
FULL PROGRAM I I NEVER
UNDERSTOOD WHY.
ON ONE OF MY FACILITY JUST FAN
RIGHT THERE.
WAVING EVERYBODY RIGHT.
BUT NOT BUT WHEN I BECAME A SO
TEMAS I REALIZED THEY WERE MAKE
HIMSELF AVAILABLE FOR ANYONE OF
US WHO HAS ANY KIND OF LIKE
QUESTIONS ON A HOMEOWNER
STRUGGLE.
WE SHARE SOMETHING MORE
AFFORDABLE AND AND ONE IS KIND
OF KIND OF FRESH.
HE WANTED TO TALK TO ABOUT IT.
AND WE GET SOME GUIDANCE WHITE
SO THEY WILL MAKE DO WHAT IT.
WILL YOU LIKE LIKE LIKE
INTERACTING WITH A SLIGHT.
AND I SHARE WITH THIS. FOR
REASONS SO.
THE BILL COMMUNITY COMMUNITY
CARES A LOVE YOU.
AND WILL BE BE THAT WHICH A NO
MATTER WHAT ALL THE WAY THROUGH
ALL TO GET OUT.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE STORIES.
TO I WAS ALSO WITH THE BOARD.
I'M A CAP ON CINEMAS HEARING.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THE BOARD.
A GOT RELEASED OUT OF PRISON IN
NOVEMBER AND THEN I END UP.
I USE N. FOR EIGHTY MUCH I WAS
FIVE MY CASE IN IMMIGRATION.
AND THE COMMITTEE BASED PROGRAMS
WAS DIFFERENT ALL THE WAY.
TO NO ONE HAS I'VE NEVER SEEN SO
MANY LIKE OP I LEFT PRISON.
PEOPLE IN THE GOT THE GOT THE
JOB THE CAN THE MOVEON.
BUT THOUSAND THAT WAS A MUST FOR
YOU KNOW LIKE THEY SHOWED UP TO
ME AND I WOULD HAVE TO KICK
PEOPLE OUT OF COURT BECAUSE THE
BLOOD WHICH COULD COMMUNICATE.
WHAT I MEAN IS THAT YOU KNOW YOU
WERE PART OF A COMMUNITY?
WE'RE GONNA BE HERE WITH YOU.
N. DISAPPOINT ME FALL YOU KNOW
SOME LETTERS TO THE GOVERNORS
AND I WAS ACTUALLY --
GOVERNOR REFER MY CASE WERE IN
BANK WITH THE BOARD OF PRO
HEARING.
OF THE FOURTEEN COMMISSIONER AND
A THEY RECOMMEND FOR MY PART IN
THE GOVERNOR VASSAL FOR ME TO
GET A PARDON.
AND THE COULD STOP THAT.
AND I SHOULD HAVE BECAUSE NOT
TOO MANY PEOPLE.
NO NO NO PRISON PROGRAM WHATEVER
TO THAT.
HE WITH YOU ALL THE WAY THROUGH
TO A POINT WHERE.
pMYSTIFIED THEY WOULD STAY IN
UNITED STATES.
AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE WHY
WOULD --
PROGRAM AT WHAT I'M SEEING ALSO
IS LIKE.
WE STRUGGLE YOU KNOW TRYING TO
HELP OUR PEOPLE.
BUT HOMES STRUGGLE FOR DOUBLE
PEOPLE HOME BECAUSE WE'RE
UNDERFUNDED.
THIS LIKE FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
THAT WAS OFFERED TO THE NOTE.
THE BILL PROGRAM THAT.
WE ARE FIGHTING FOR THE SAME
THING AND LIKE.
LIKE HOW DO YOU.
SUPPORT PROGRAM MORE RIGHT I
DON'T THINK SHOULD TAKE MORE.
THE STUFF OUT OF PROGRAM AT THE
CITY SO OFTEN THE PROGRAM IS
NEEDED THE PROGRAM ALSO.
HAVEN'T BUT ON WHAT WHAT WOULD
THEY COULD GET SUPPORT AS WELL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HOW MUCH I'M IN IT TRY TO KEEP
THIS REALLY BRIEF CONCISE? ONE
MORE ITEM.
ARMED MY NAME IS AMANDA BURGER
ON THE PROGRAM DIRECTOR WITHIN
SAY CURTAIN PROGRAM WHERE OF
FORTY EIGHT WEEK CURRICULUM.
ALL IS TO RECONNECT PEOPLE TO
SPELL.
COMMUNITY IN THE NATURAL WORLD.
ACTUALLY NATIONALLY I'M ALSO A
FOUNDING MEMBER OF W. AND I ON
THE BOARD OF FUND COMMON LAW --
ONE IS FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
CONTEXT WE WORKING NINE PRISONS
AND CALIFORNIA SPENDING HEALTH
FACILITIES WOMEN'S FACILITIES
WORK WITH PEOPLE OR THINGS LIKE
THAT.
PEOPLE FACING LIFE WITHOUT THE
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE WITH YOUTH
AND I ALSO MANAGER PROGRAM ON
EACH UNIT AT SAN QUENTIN.
MOST PEOPLE ARE FAMILIAR WITH
THE UPPER YARD IT'S AND CLINTON.
PLACE CALLED H. UNIT WHICH IS
WHERE THE MEN LIVE WHO HAVE TO
TERMINATE DATES WHO WERE GOING
HOME IN EIGHT YEARS OR LESS
[inaudible]
ON I WANTED TO SAY THE JUST
ANECDOTALLY ESPECIALLY ON EACH
UNIT WE DO WE WORK FROM TO
SUPPORT REENTRY NEEDS WITH
PEOPLE IT OFTEN ALL AND ALSO IT
FULL SERVE WOMEN'S FACILITIES.
AND I WANNA SAY ANECDOTALLY IT'S
NOT UNUSUAL FOR US TO HAVE
PARTICIPANTS.
WHO EVEN A MONTH BEFORE THEY GO
HOME HAVE NO IDEA WHERE THEY'RE
GOING?
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO BE LIVING
WHAT THEY'RE AND PORT THEM --
AS A RESULT OF THAT WE NOW IT
SAYS THE NEED PEOPLE BEFORE THEY
LEAVE PRESENT SO WE CAN CONNECT
THEM WITH TRUSTED SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES EMPLOYERS AND SOCIAL
NETWORKS.
I WANT TO FOCUS MY REMARKS TODAY
ON A OUR FOCUS GROUP THAT WE DID
WITH CHIEF WENDY STILL FROM
ALAMEDA COUNTY AND THE MAN ON A
UNIT THIS SUMMER.
ARE IN AUGUST AND WE ASK THEM TO
QUESTIONS WE ASKED THE MEN TO
QUESTIONS.
IF YOU HAD THE POWER TO DESIGN
RE RELEASED PROGRAMMING WHAT
WOULD YOU DO.
WHAT NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED TO BE
SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION GOING HOME?
HERE ARE SOME OF THEIR RESPONSES.
WE NEED TRAINED COUNSELORS WITH
FEWER PEOPLE ON THEIR CASE LOADS
RIGHT NOW WE CAN BARELY SEE OUR
COUNSELORS ON A REGULAR BASIS.
WE NEED A SKYPE SYSTEM TO
CONNECT PEOPLE WITH PAROLE
AGENTS PRIOR TO RELEASE AND WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS TO BUILD THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS WITH OUR AGENTS
BEFORE LEAVING.
WE NEED JOB TRAINING THAT
MATCHES THE MARKET ECONOMY MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR
APPRENTICESHIPS AND CONNECTIONS
TO UNIONS BEFORE GOING HOME.
WE NEED BETTER COORDINATION WITH
COMMUNITY BASED PROGRAMS AND
VOLUNTEER PROGRAMS COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS OFTEN HAVE THE
MOST TRUSTED RELATIONSHIPS WITH
US.
AND THUS CAN PLAY A ROLE IN OUR
REENTRY IF ALLOWED BY THE CDC
ARE IMPRISONED STAFF.
ON ONE THING I THINK YOU ALL
NEED TO KNOW IS THERE ARE
ACTUALLY SOME TECHNICAL BARRIERS.
THAT PREVENT US FROM HAVING
ONGOING RELATIONSHIPS WITH
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN OUR PROGRAMS
ONCE THEY PAROLE.
WE NEED THE ABILITY TO TRANSFER
PEOPLE ERA AND TRANSFER PAROLE
INDOOR PROBATION TWO DIFFERENT
COUNTIES BASED ON WHERE MORE
OPPORTUNITIES MIGHT EXIST.
NOT ALL COUNTIES ARE CREATED
EQUAL AND I PERSONALLY HAVE HAD
THE EXPERIENCE WITH SOMEONE
BEING FORCED TO PAROLE. TO
TURLOCK FOR EXAMPLE HAD HE GONE
TO STOCKTON WHICH WAS RIGHT NEXT
DOOR HE WOULD HAVE HAD ACCESS TO
A NUMBER OF SERVICES BUT THERE
WAS NOTHING IN THAT COUNTY.
WE NEED MORE FOCUS ON PROGRAMS
GEARED TOWARDS MEN ON EACH UNIT
PROGRAMS GEARED TOWARDS MEN THAT
HAVE TO TERMINATE DATE CENTER
GOING HOME.
WELL SAN QUENTIN KNEW SO WELL
KNOWN TO ALL OF US FEW VENTURE
EACH UNIT.
WE NEED MORE PROGRAMS PRE
RELEASE THAT ADEQUATELY PREPARE
MANNING WOMEN TO DEAL WITH
REENTRY REALITIES.
FAMILY REUNIFICATION RELAPSE
CLIMENT POTENTIAL PAROLE
VIOLATIONS WE NEED MORE FORMALLY
INCARCERATED PEOPLE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE TO GUIDE US.
AND TALK WITH US TO PREPARE US
FOR THE CHALLENGES ON THE
OUTSIDE AND FINALLY ONE LAST
RECOMMENDATION THEY HAD.
WE NEED TO BRING THE PACK
MEETINGS BACK INSIDE THE PRISONS.
SO THAT SERVICES SO THAT PEOPLE
INSIDE CAN MEET PEOPLE OFFERING
SERVICES AND DEVELOP
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THEM BEFORE
THEY GO HOME.
POTENTIALLY EACH BUILDING
SIGNING UP FOR PROGRAMS AND I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
BUT WHEN PEOPLE.
ROLE THEY GO TO ACT MUNICH
MEETING IN THE COMMUNITY AND
THERE'S KIND OF LIKE A ONE STOP
SHOPPING WHERE YOU KIND OF LIKE
DO SOME QUICK SPEED DATING WITH
THE PROGRAM.
WE FEEL VERY STRONGLY
RELATIONSHIPS ARE KEY.
PROGRAMS NEED TO BE INSIDE
PRISONS PRIOR TO PEOPLE LEAVING
SO THE RELATIONSHIPS THE TRUST
IN THE COMMUNICATION CAN START
BEFORE THEY GO HOME.
AN WE THINK THAT THIS WOULD
REALLY --
HELP THE POOR PEOPLE BEING MORE
SUCCESSFUL.
MY LAST COMMENT.
ON WHEN I FIRST STARTED DOING
THIS WORK IT WENT IN AS A
VOLUNTEER I MET A GENTLEMAN
SERVING A LIFE SENTENCE.
TOLD ME WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO COME
FROM HIGH DESERT PRISON TO SAN
QUENTIN.
HE SPOKE ABOUT THE FEELING OF
BEING DEAD AND THEN COMING BACK
TO LIFE.
THAT'S WHAT MOTIVATES THE WORK
WE'RE DOING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SO WITH THAT.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE.
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT I WANT TO
THANK OUR TWO WITNESSES FOR
SHARING.
YOUR INSIGHTS AND
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US AND I WANT
TO THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
GOOD QUESTIONS.
AND THIS WAS INFORMATIONAL BUT
OF COURSE WE ARE GOING TO BE.
BEFORE.
ON JUNE FIFTEENTH.
WALKING DOWN ON SOME.
APPROPRIATIONS FOR OUR
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS AND JUST
OUR GENERAL CORRECTIONS BUDGET
SO I THINK A LOT OF THE THINGS
THAT WE LEARNED TODAY WILL HELP
INFORM US AS WE MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
OUR NEXT ITEM.
IN THANKS SO MUCH.
IN OUR NEXT ITEM --
RELATES TO WHAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT WE WERE ABLE LAST
YEAR TO SECURE IN THE BUDGET.
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS ON A ONE
TIME BASIS FOR REENTRY.
A SUPPORTING VERSION SUPPORT.
AND WAS PRIMARILY FOCUSED ON
HOUSING SUPPORT WHICH WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD TODAY IS A VERY
CRITICAL ISSUE FOR WHEN PEOPLE
ARE.
RELEASED ON AND WHAT WE WANT TO
HEAR TODAY FROM OUR BOARD OF
STATE AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
IN RELATIONSHIP TO THAT THE
FUNDING THAT WE APPROVED LAST
YEAR IS [inaudible]
OF WHAT I UNDERSTAND THE R. F.
P. FOR THAT MONEY IS OUT IN THE
FIELD NOW WHAT I'D LIKE TO KNOW
IS.
WHAT OUR --
WHAT WAS THE RESPONSE?
OF MEANING THE INTEREST SO FAR
RATE WHAT'S BEEN THE INTEREST.
WHAT'S YOUR TIME LINE FOR
AWARDING GRAHAM LESSONS LEARNED
FROM THE PROCESS.
SO.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ON
KATIE HOWARD THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BSE SEE GETTING
OVER A LITTLE COLD HERE FOR FOR
GIVE ME.
ON WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME TODAY AND
PROVIDE AN UPDATE --
I WANT TO THANK YOU IN
PARTICULAR SENATOR SKINNER THIS
WAS YOUR PROPOSAL FROM LAST YEAR
THE ADULT RE ENTRY GRANT.
AND THE BOARD OF STATE AND
COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS --
FOR THE BENEFIT OF THE COMMITTEE --
ADMINISTERS A WIDE RANGE OF
DIFFERENT SORTS OF GRANTS THIS
ADULT RE ENTRY PROGRAM WAS ON
SIMILAR TO OTHER KINDS OF GRANTS
THAT THE BOARD IS ADMINISTERING
AND SO I THINK OUR OUR EXPERTISE
WAS RECOGNIZED IN TERMS OF
RECEIVING THIS FUNDING.
ON THERE IS THE R. F. P. WAS
APPROVED BY THE BOARD IN JANUARY
AND WAS PUT OUT INTO THE FIELD
THOSE PROPOSALS ARE ACTUALLY DO
NEXT MONDAY THERE HAS BEEN IN
RESPONSE TO YOUR QUESTION
SENATOR A TREMENDOUS.
AMOUNT OF INTEREST OF FROM THE
FIELD WE ASK PEOPLE TO SUBMIT A
LETTER OF INTENT TO APPLY IN
THOSE LETTERS OF INTENT WERE DUE
IN FEBRUARY WE HAVE ALREADY
RECEIVED OVER ONE HUNDRED AND
SIXTY EIGHT INDICATIONS OF IN AN
INTENTION TO APPLY.
THERE COULD BE FEWER THERE COULD
BE MORE THAT LETTER OF INTENT
BUT WE JUST FOR PURPOSES OF
PLANNING OUR WORK WE LIKE TO
KNOW ABOUT HOW MANY --
APPLICATIONS ARE RATHER
PROPOSALS TO EXPECT --
CENTER SKINNER OF COURSE WAS
ABLE TO COME TO ONE OF THE FIRST
EXECUTIVES DURING COMMITTEES
LAST FALL AND SHARE HER VISION
FOR THIS.
ON THE COMPONENTS FOR FINDING
THAT ARE OUT IN THE FELD RIGHT
NOW ARE TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE I
JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE CAN APPLY.
FOR SO INDIVIDUAL PROGRAMS CAN
APPLY FOR UP TO THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO PROVIDE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE SERVICES OVER THE
APPROXIMATELY THREE YEAR GRANT
PERIOD.
AND THEN IN ADDITION THERE IS
NINE POINT THREE FIVE MILLION
FOR WARM HAND OFF SERVICES AND
ALSO A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
WHAT WE MEANT WHEN WE SAID THOSE
TWO THINGS --
WHEN THOSE?
GRAMS CAN REQUEST UP TO FIVE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
GRANT PERIOD --
WE HAVE RECEIVED LIKE I SAID A
HUNDRED MORE THAN A HUNDRED
SIXTY MORE OF CONTINUE TO COME
IN MY TEAM HAS TOLD ME FROM ALL
ACROSS THE STATE.
ON THE FORTY STATE COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS FORMED AN EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE WHICH IS
ACTUALLY CHAIRED BY THE CHAIR OF
OUR BOARD LINDA TANNER.
ON THE EXPERTISE ON THE
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEE IS
JUST TREMENDOUS INCLUDING
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS ON
POLICY EXPERT ON HOUSING --
IT'S IT'S JUST A TREMENDOUS
GROUP I'M HAPPY TO SHARE THAT
ROSTER ON WITH YOU MISTER
FRANCIS IF YOU LIKED YOUR WITH
THE COMMITTEE.
ON SO -- THE
THE APPLICATIONS AS I MENTIONED
ARE DUE NEXT MONDAY AND THERE'S
A RATHER ON BROAD RANGE OF LINES
OF SERVICES THAT CAN BE A FIVE
OR SO FOCUSING FIRST ON THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE COMPONENT.
WE PROVIDED A LIST AND THE
COMMITTEE HAD.
DEEP DISCUSSIONS ABOUT ALL OF
THIS THEY WANTED --
TO PUT SOME BROAD PARAMETER AND
THEN BECAUSE IT IS A COMPETITIVE
GRANT PROGRAM BASICALLY SEE HOW
THE FIELD RESPONDED WE HAVE A A
PROCESS BY WHICH THERE ARE
READING CRITERIA BUILT INTO THE
R. F. P..
THE PROPOSALS WILL BE SCORED AND
THE AWARDS WILL BE MADE AT THE
BOARD MEETING IN JULY OF THIS
YEAR.
SO THE RENTAL ASSISTANCE
SERVICES COULD INCLUDE AND ARE
NOT LIMITED TO SHORT TERM
EMERGENCY HOUSING ASSISTANCE
LANDLORD INCENTIVES RENT
SUBSIDIES VOUCHERS MOVING COSTS.
AVERAGE OF BACK GRANT STIPENDS
TO FAMILIES WHO ARE WILLING TO
HOUSE OF PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
STATE PRISON.
ON TRANSITIONAL HOUSING --
BROAD RANGE OF RENTAL RELATED --
A NEEDS AND THEN ON THE WARM
HAND OFF AND IT WAS EALLY
INTERESTING TO NOTE ON THE WARM
HAND OFF IS A NINE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLAR.
PART OF FUNDING AND WE RECEIVED --
EVEN MORE LETTERS OF INTENT FOR
THAT WARM HAND OFF --
RE ENTRY SERVICE PART OF THE R.
F. P. SO THOSE SERVICES CAN
INCLUDE AND MANY OF THE SPEAKERS
ON THE LAST PANEL AS WELL AS THE
PUBLIC COMMENT.
THAT YOU'VE JUST RECEIVED ON
TOUCHED ON THE KINDS OF RE ENTRY
SERVICES THAT ARE NEEDED.
SO IT CAN INCLUDE CASE
MANAGEMENT SERVICES I THINK THAT
IS SIGNIFICANTLY WHAT --
THESE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING TO BE
PROVIDING REALLY IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT THIS ENTIRE GRANT
PROGRAM.
ON THE ONLY ELIGIBLE APPLICANTS
ARE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS SO VERY CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT YOU'VE BEEN HEARING
TODAY.
IT CAN INCLUDE CASE MANAGEMENT
REGION SERVICES TO MAKE THOSE
CONNECTIONS WHEN SOMEONE IS
PREPARING ON TO TO LEAVE STATE
PRISON HOUSING NAVIGATION
SERVICES TRANSPORTATION FOOD
EMERGENCY SERVICES EMPLOYMENT
VOCATIONAL SOCIAL SERVICES
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH CARE.
MENTOR SYSTEM --
AND SYSTEM NOW THE AND WE'LL SEE
WHAT THESE PROPOSALS INCLUDE AS
THEY COME IN BUT THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS ARE GOING TO
LAY OUT WHAT THEY PROPOSE IN
TERMS OF CASE MANAGEMENT.
BASED NEEDS ASSESSMENT SO THAT
PEOPLE TO RE ENTRY.
AND THE MATCH SO I'D LIKE TO
STOP THERE AND SEE WHAT
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND HAPPY TO
PROVIDE ANY ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION --
THAT THE COMMITTEE MAY WANT.
MORRELL A WHAT I WOULD LIKE YOU
TO TALK SOME ABOUT IS THE THE
FOCUS OF THE WELL IT WAS YES
TERM REENTRY SUPPORT THE FOCUS
WAS.
ON RECOGNIZING THAT HOUSING IS
SUCH A CRITICAL NEED AND SO
DIFFICULT.
HIGH COST OF HOUSING CALIFORNIA --
THAT ALREADY IS A HUGE BARRIER
BUT ADDITIONALLY --
AS A PERSON WITH THE RECORD --
MOST LANDLORDS IF THEY DO A
BACKGROUND CHECK AREN'T REALLY
JUMPING UP AND DOWN TO ONE A
RENT TO YOU --
AND ANYWAY SO --
A GOOD AMOUNT OF OUR MOTIVATION
WAS TO PROVIDE --
AS MUCH HOUSING SUPPORT AS
POSSIBLE AND THE GRANT AS YOU
MENTIONED DID DO THE RENTAL BUT
WHAT PROBLEMS DID YOU ENCOUNTER
IN.
THE ADMINISTERING OF THE PROGRAM
THAT WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND IF WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TRYING TO FIND
GOOD HOUSING SUPPORT.
ON WELL I WOULD SAY THAT
SPECIFICALLY ABOUT THE RENTAL
ASSISTANCE COMPONENT OF THE R.
F. P. ON WE HAVEN'T YET SEEN
WHAT THOSE PROPOSED IT I WOULD
LIKE YOU TO TALK BROADER BECAUSE
THE REASON IT'S ONLY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IN OURS.
HE ISN'T AS OF SOME OF THE
PROBLEMS YOU ENCOUNTER OKAY WE
REALLY HAD BROADER IN MINE RIGHT
AB SIDE THE BOARD CHOSE TO
LIMITED.
AND SO I WANT THE COMMITTEE TO
UNDERSTAND WHY IT WAS LIMóN
OKAY SURE I CAN DO THAT SENATOR
ON SO ONE OF THE COMPONENTS AT A
AT A THIRD COMPONENT OF THIS
GRANT WAS TO BE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR THE REHABILITATION OF
EXISTING PROPERTY TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR PEOPLE COMING OUT OF
STATE PRISON.
AND AS THE EXECUTIVE STEERING
COMMITTEE --
ENDEAVOR THROUGH SEVERAL
MEETINGS IN THE FALL THERE WERE
A NUMBER OF LEGAL AND POLICY AND
ON MONITORING QUESTIONS THAT
CAME UP AND WE'RE STILL WORKING
ON THAT INTERNALLY AND AND IN
COMMUNICATION WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND OF
COURSE THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE.
ON HOW BEST TO MOVE FORWARD ON
THAT ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE
DID WAS TO HAVE DONE A FAIRLY-EXTENSIVE.
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT AND SOME
OF THE LEGAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
PROVIDING --
HOUSING IS SOMETHING AS ONE
EXAMPLE JUST ONE EXAMPLE IS IS
IF IF THERE'S A REHABILITATION
PROJECT THAT THE STATE IS
FUNDING --
THERE COULD BE A RESPONSIBILITY
TO COVER RELOCATION THIS IS FOR
SOMEONE WHO MIGHT BE LIVING IN A
PLACE WHERE THERE'S TO BE.
ON A REMODEL OR YOU KNOW SOME
SOME IMPROVEMENTS MADE AND SO WE
WANTED TO BE SURE THAT WE
UNDERSTOOD ALL OF THE
COMPLEXITIES OF THE LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS.
WE ALSO FELT LIKE AND AND AND IN
CONSULTATION WITH YOUR OFFICE
SENATOR THAT IT WAS REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US TO MOVE FORWARD.
ON THE OTHER TWO COMPONENTS THE
RENTAL ASSISTANCE AND THE WARM
HAND OFF WHICH WERE A LITTLE BIT
LESS COMPLEX LEGALLY AND IN
TERMS OF THE MONEY.
AND ALL THAT SO WHILE I THINK WE
CAN YOU KNOW MAKE SOME DECISIONS
ABOUT HOW THE REHABILITATION OF
EXISTING PER IN DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT ABOUT THOSE ISSUES.
JUST FOR THE COMMITTEE.
TO THE BEFORE THE RFP WAS
DEVELOPED.
WE HAD HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF
NONPROFITS IN DIFFERENT.
ALL CALM AGENCY THEY WEREN'T
NECESSARILY GOVERNMENT BASS
THOUGH MANY OF THEM HAD RECEIVED
GOVERNMENT FUNDING.
THAT --
BASICALLY WERE.
WHAT THEY DID WAS PROVIDE?
IN FACT.
ALL SEE TRANSITIONAL HOUSING BUT
IT WAS A BIT DIFFERENT THAN WE
HEARD FROM OUR OUR PREVIOUS
SPEAKER SO WASN'T RESTRICTIVE
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING WAS MORE.
LIKE HOUSING LITERALLY FOR
REENTRY FOLKS AND THAT WAS THE
THE VERY.
A MISSION THAT THOSE NONPROFITS
WERE INVOLVED IN AN AMITY COMES
TO MIND THERE'S OTHERS.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THEY
RECOGNIZE IS THAT THERE WERE
PROPERTIES THAT WERE AVAILABLE
BUT WHAT THEY NEEDED WAS THE
MONEY TO PUT HIM INTO SHAPE.
TO TO THEN HOUSE MORE PEOPLE AND
SUCH.
AND SO IN THE CONSTRUCTION --
ORIGINALLY OF THE R. P. THINGS
WE ARE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH THIS
FUNDING THAT.
BUT WHAT WE ENCOUNTERED WERE A
VARIETY OF WE JUST ENCOUNTERED A
VARIETY OF LEGAL ISSUES AND THEY
WORK IT'S NOT THAT STATE FUNDING
CAN'T DO THAT IT WAS MORE.
THAT OUR WE HAVE SOME AGENCIES
THAT ARE USED TO THAT.
AND THEY HAVE A CERTAIN --
PROCEDURES AND THEN OF COURSE
BSE SEE HAD NEVER DONE THAT
BEFORE AND SO SHOULD WE HAVE IT
IN THE HANDS OF THE OTHER
AGENCIES SO THEY WERE JUST
ISSUES LIKE THAT WHICH AT SOME
POINT WE DON'T HAVE --
TO HAVE THAT ALL PRESENTED NOW
BUT I WOULD LIKE SOME KIND
SOMETHING.
IN WRITING ONLY SO THAT IF WE
INTEND. TO MOVE FORWARD IF WE
WERE SO --
SUCCESSFULLY GETTING ADDITIONAL
FUNDING --
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO DESIGN
IT SO THAT THIS WAS NOT AN
OBSTACLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
FOR GO AHEAD --
ONE OF THE LOWER THE ITEMS THAT
YOU'RE GOING TO BE FUNDING.
ON THE HOUSING AND OR I ASSUME
THAT.
YOU'RE.
GOING TO HAVE THESE APPLICANTS
SHOW HOW THEY'RE APPLYING.
FOR OTHER FUNDS AND MAYBE
LEVERAGE THE MONEY THAT YOU'RE --
HAVING. TO BE USED FOR LIKE
FEDERAL FUNDS THE OTHER STATE
FUNDS.
THAT ARE OUT THERE LOCAL HOUSING
OF THAT THEY NEED LIKE IF THEY
WANTED TO DO REAL BILL TATIAN
THAT COULD GO TO THE YOU KNOW
THE LOCAL HOUSING.
PROGRAMS THAT FUND THAT KIND OF
STUFF THIS CD BG.
FEDERAL PROGRAM FUNDS RE --
SO DO THE WHEN YOU VALUE ITEM TO
THE SHOW --
OTHER USING THE MONEY THAT
THEY'RE LINE FOR WITH YOU TO
LEVERAGE.
GETTING SOME OF THOSE OTHER
GRANTS.
ON THE PART OF IT --
I'M JUST SCANNING VERY YOU KNOW
IRAN SAYING I DO UNDERSTAND YOUR
QUESTION CENTER IN GETTING
THROUGH ARE.
THE BASIC RATING CRITERIA WE
TALK ABOUT LET'S SEE HERE
ORIGINALLY.
AND IN THE BUDGET INFORMATION WE
GENERALLY ASK THE APPLICANTS TO
TALK ABOUT OTHER FUNDING SOURCES
THAT ARE BEING LEVERAGED --
SO I CAN GIVE YOU --
FURTHER DETAIL AFTER OF A YOUNG
WORK PLACED IT IN THE R. F. P.
BUT THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WE
TYPICALLY DO IS TALK ABOUT
LEVERAGING FUNDING AND IN.
SO WILL YOU WE CAN FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ON THAT.
LIKE WE HAVE LIKE PROGRAMS --
LIKE PROPOSITION ONE WE PASSED
LAST YEAR --
THE BOND FUND.
AS MONEY FOR THIS THING --
IT HAS MONEY --
FOR US SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
RIGHT OF PROGRAMS --
WHICH IS KIND OF WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT ABOUT A HOUSING
UNIT WITH.
YOU KNOW CRAZY A I DON'T THINK
THE REALLY BIG.
PROJECTS OR ANYTHING BUT MAYBE --
OF A PLACE FOR PEOPLE TO LIVE
MAYBE. SIX PEOPLE.
SMALL --
THEY HAVE A HOUSE IN EITHER
MAYBE FIX IT UP A LITTLE BIT IS
THAT WOULD KIND OF WHEN YOU SAY
RE AB THAT'S ARTS CENTER WAS SO
SO --
SOMETIMES THESE FUNDS THAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT.
JUST SAY HAVE LIKE LESS
[inaudible]
THERE YEARS.
ABSOLUTELY --
AND SOMETIMES YOU CAN USE THOSE
FUNDS FOR SOME OF THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS.
AND MAYBE THE MONEY YOU HAVE.
FOR THE WHAT HE CALLED THE WARM
HAND OFF YEAH THAT.
ONE THE SUPPORT OF PROGRAMS
RIGHT LAST WEEK'S WILL JUST ONE
I DON'T KNOW I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S JUST YOU KNOW I THINK
YEAH I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THE PROPOSAL IS TO
LOOK AT HOW THEY'RE USING THE
OTHER FUNDS.
EVERY EVERY LARGE COUNTY HAS OF
A FUN LIKE THIS I MEAN ORANGE
COUNTY DOES.
SET MY COUNTY SAN JOSE DOES.
OR MEDIA.
ALL THE COUNTIES HAVE THESE
HOUSING FUNDS.
AND THE THEIR FUNDS ARE PRETTY
PRETTY.
FLEXIBLE IN THEIR USE RIGHT NOW
FOR THESE KINDS OF SERVICES OKAY
SO YOU CAN YOU CAN --
YOU CAN LEVERAGE THE MONEY YOU
HAVE HERE. FOR THESE APPLICANTS --
VERY WELL I THINK IF YOU YOU SET
THAT UP RIGHT.
I THINK THAT'S RIGHT AND I AND I
ALSO THINK THAT THAT REALLY WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO FIND BECAUSE WE
YOU KNOW THAT THEY EXPECTED
DURING COMMITTEE ITSELF WILL BE
THE ONES.
REVIEWING AND RATING THE
PROPOSAL'S YOU KNOW I I IS STAFF
DON'T GET INVOLVED IN THAT BUT
WHAT I ANTICIPATE WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IN THOSE PROPOSALS.
IS A CLEAR.
INDICATION FROM THE PEOPLE ON
WINE FOR THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
UNDERSTAND THE NEEDS OF THE
TARGET.
AND IN ADDITION TO UNDERSTANDING
HOUSING NEEDS THEY ARE EQUIPPED
TO YOU KNOW PROVIDE THE
ASSISTANCE AND IT AS A MATTER OF
A POLICY BASIS I THINK IT'S ALSO.
HELPFUL THINGS THAT WAS --
IMPORTANT FOR OUR EXECUTIVE
STEERING COMMITTEE THE WELL
BRIEFED ON BY SOME OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ABOUT
THE CONCEPT OF HOUSING FOR WHICH
I THINK MEMBERS ON THIS
COMMITTEE ARE.
FAMILIAR WITH AND IT IS A A
POLICY THAT SAYS THAT.
THE FUNDING FOR THE HOUSING AND
THE THE THE YOU KNOW THE THE THE
HOUSING RELATED SERVICES AND
SUBSIDIES.
HAVE TO BE PROVIDED PEOPLE WITH
OUT STRINGS ATTACHED SO JUST YOU
KNOW IN IN PART IN RESPONSE TO
YOUR COMMENT SENATOR ABOUT THAT
YOU KNOW THERE CAN'T BE A
REQUIREMENT THAT SOMEONE.
HAS TO BE SOBER IN IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THE HOUSING SERVICES IT
IT IS ON SEPT THAT HOUSING AS TO
BE PROVIDED FIRST SO THAT THAT
LEVEL OF FOUNDATION IS --
PROVIDED FOR SOMEBODY WHO'S.
COMING OUT OF STATE PRISON.
ORDER TO PURSUE YOUR TREATMENT
IF YOU ARE NOT HOUSE STUFF.
YEAH ANY QUESTIONS FURTHER.
OKAY WELL WE LOOK FORWARD --
TO HEARING ABOUT HOW MANY
APPLICATIONS AT ACTUAL PROPOSALS
ARE RECEIVED.
AND WHETHER THE AMOUNT REQUESTED
IS.
YOU KNOW ABOUT AROUND WHAT WE
HAVE AVAILABLE OR QUADRUPLE TIME.
INTERSIL ITEM MORE I'LL BE AND
THEN -- YEAH
SO MUCH.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS ITEM.
ALL RIGHT WITH THAT THERE'S NO
OTHER COMMENTS FROM MY
COLLEAGUES THEN WE WILL.
OF OUR SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE WILL
STAND.
ADJOURNED